Jetzt geht's aber los zum letzten Mal in diesem Jahr, zum letzten Mal in diesem Monat an einem Donnerstag ein Blue Moon und zum letzten Mal auch mit Leuten vom Chaos Computer Club, die ja immer am letzten Donnerstag hier das Radio übernehmen und machen, was sie wollen, glaube ich.
Oder?
Wir machen alles, was du sagst.
Ihr seid so lieb.
Vom Chaos Computer Club sind heute da Erdgeist, hallo und guten Abend.
Wunderschönen guten Abend.
THS.
Guten Tag.
Und Maha. Hallo. Und im Gegensatz zu normalerweise machen wir heute nicht ein Thema, was wir euch in aller Ausführlichkeit auswalzen, bis zum Ende, sondern einen kleinen Rückblick, denn wir haben ja ein Jahr gehabt, das die Nummer 2012 trägt. Ende des Jahres geht dann die Welt unter und davor ist noch viel Kram passiert, der so mit dem komischen Internet, von dem wir mal alle reden, zu tun haben, oder mit Computern oder mit dem Telefon, die in der Hosentasche ab. Und wir wollen mal gucken, was da so alles irgendwie am Start war. So, liebe Herren, wir hatten ja da ja möglicherweise die ein oder andere Urheberrechtsdebatte. Ja, ja, ich würde mal bei dem Thema anfangen wollen, dass das bei allen sozusagen am präsentesten ist, nämlich Musik. So frag ich mich, soll ich den Erdgeist zuerst fragen? Nein, das machen wir später. Mit dem Tracker das meine ich. Ist denn euch irgendwie das persönlich aufgetreten, angetreten, Verwandte abgemahnt worden, irgendwas mit der Musik passiert dieses Jahr? Also so Filesharing, Tauschbörsen mäßig?
Nö, es ist schon wohl sich rumgesprochen zu haben, dass man ein bisschen Datenhygiene betreiben muss, wenn man seine Musik aus dem Internet holt. Vielleicht ist ja Creative Commons Musik einfach auch viel populärer geworden. Kann man sich hier wünschen?
Ja, das würde ich mir wünschen. Tatsächlich habe ich aus dem, naja, nicht direkten, aber weiteren Unfeld doch häufiger mal gehört, dass ist noch jemand verklagt worden. Also nicht unbedingt, weil er selber, also nicht verklagt, sondern abgemahnt, nicht weil er unbedingt selber getauscht hat, aber sozusagen dieses Oh mein Gott, ich bin abgemahnt worden, dabei habe ich doch gar nicht getauscht, aber ich hatte zu dieser Zeit vielleicht versucht, dann war es jemand anders und so weiter. Also das ist immer noch Thema.
Ja, da gibt es ja auch die ganzen Tor-Exit-Notbetreiber, die da schon ihre Standards schreiben haben. Es gibt Leute, die in den freien Netzen, in den Bürgernetzen unterwegs sind, die dann auch für Leute, denen sie das Internet zur Verfügung stellen, dann den Kopf hinhalten, aber das hat man auch schon vor, glaube ich, drei Chaos-Radiosen gesprochen.
Ja, aber du bist doch zu Boden tief irgendwie. Es ist doch nicht alles wunderbar.
Okay, das habe ich nicht gesagt. Ich habe nur in meinem Freundeskreis einfach so wenig davon gehört.
Na ja, aber man hört auch von Leuten, die sogar abgemahnt werden für Creative Commons-Musik, weil es diese GEMA-Vermutung gibt. Und erst mal die GEMA sagt, ja Moment, da veröffentlicht jemand was unter Pseudonym, da muss aber gezahlt werden. Wenn das Pseudonym ist, dann könnte der Herr Mitglied der GEMA sein. Dann nehmen wir das erst mal an. Also sowas hat es ja auch gegeben.
Da spielst du an auf den Open Music Sampler?
Genau.
Nee, Free Music Sampler heißt ja mit, aber ich komme mal durcheinander. Genau, der einmal im Jahr rauskommt, wo freie Musik ist, und die sind ja verklagt worden für den vom letzten Jahr, für die Band Texas Dragonfly.
Und haben ja daraufhin, finde ich, die vor das Gericht gezogen, haben Berufen eingelegt, sind damit auch geschaltet und haben dieses Jahr auf den Sampler dann wieder ein Lied von der Band draufgemacht.
Ich glaube diesmal sogar drei Lieder.
Aber nicht von derselben Band.
Nein, nein, aber drei Lieder mit dem Pseudonym.
Okay, sind die da jetzt auch schon verklagt worden?
Noch nicht, aber das wird jetzt kommen. Der neue Free Music Sampler ist ja jetzt gerade erst vor zwei Wochen oder was rausgekommen. Jedenfalls ich habe ihn erst vor zwei Wochen bekommen. Und das geht natürlich jetzt wieder rund.
Glaubt ihr, man wird dieses mit dem Urheberrecht irgendwann nochmal klären?
Was ist dann klären? Es ist ja eigentlich immer ein Abwägen zwischen den Befindlichkeiten und Erwartungen von Künstlern und der Bevölkerung, die ja auch irgendwie bezahlen möchten. Und da muss man immer den neuen technischen Gegebenheiten das anpassen, wie man meint, der gerechnen Lohn. Das wird immer in Verhandlung bleiben. Bloß dieser rauhe Ton generell. Ihr seid ja alle kriminell, diese Vorwürfe, die werden dann vielleicht...
Nein, du bist kriminell. Ich? Aber nicht im Zusammenhang. Das ist... Ich habe dieses Jahr keine neuen technischen Gegebenheiten kennengelernt. Wofür? Für Musikverbreitung.
Mit der Beschleunigung meine ich schon, dass sich über die letzten 15 Jahre solche Dinge geändert haben und dort Leute jetzt überrascht sind.
Jetzt hat Maha gerade das schöne Wort GEMA-Vermutung gesagt. Kannst du das noch mal kurz genauer erklären?
Na ja, also die GEMA, die ja eben die Verwertungsrechte irgendwie vertritt, die sagt eben, also Musik ist erstmal geschützt und erstmal gehen wir davon aus, dass wir kassieren dürfen. Und wenn man halt der Meinung ist, dass man nicht zahlen muss an die GEMA, weil man eben gemeinfreie Musik oder Creative Commons Musik verwendet, dann muss man unter Umständen selber nachweisen, dass die Musik, die man da gespielt hat, tatsächlich auch nicht dazu führt, dass man was bezahlen muss. Also muss man selber beweisen, also die GEMA geht erstmal davon aus, alle Musik ist erstmal zahlungspflichtig.
Das erinnert mich ein bisschen ans Leistungsschutzrecht, da kommen wir dann gleich noch zu. Also nochmal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, die GEMA sagt, also alle Musik, die ihr spielt, die hat mit uns zu tun, im Zweifel. Und das liegt daran, dass die GEMA die einzige Verwertungsgesellschaft ist, die wir hier haben. Also zumindest für Musik.
Das wurde ja auch erst vor, glaube ich, drei Wochen nochmal von der Regierung bestätigt, dass sie dort wenig Grund haben zur Annahme, dass dem inzwischen nicht mehr so ist und dass sie die GEMA-Vermutung auch auf absehbare Zeit nicht nochmal verhandeln wollen.
Und das liegt ja daran, dass es halt keine andere Verwertungsgesellschaft gibt. Und da wiederum sind seit Jahren, zumindest gefühlt bei mir, Leute dran mal was anderes zu bauen, nämlich die sogenannte C3S, eine Verwertungsgesellschaft, die genau auch eine Verwertungsgesellschaft für Musik sein soll. Und da hilft jetzt mittlerweile jemand mit, mit der rechtlichen Betreuung, der möglicherweise aus anderen Gründen bekannt ist. Meinhard Stachostick ist der Typ, der die Vorratsartenspeicherung, Sammelklage oder wie auch immer man das juristisch korrekt ausdrückt, an den Start gebracht hat, der ist außerdem mittlerweile am Verfassungsgericht in Berlin. Und im Rahmen dessen, dass er für die C3S auch was macht, jetzt am Telefon. Hallo und guten Abend.
Danke für die Einführung.
Gerne. Wir haben jetzt gerade schon gelernt, was die GEMA-Vermutung ist. Wir wissen auch, die C3S soll das irgendwie aufbrechen vielleicht. Was genau ist der Plan hinter der C3S?
Also C3S wird das nicht aufbrechen, sondern das ist schon im Gesetz aufgebrochen. Die GEMA-Vermutung gilt nur, solange es nur eine Urheberwahrnehmungsgesellschaft gibt. Das ist im Urheberwahrnehmungsgesetz so geregelt. Und wenn es eine zweite Wahrnehmungsgesellschaft gibt, dann gilt die GEMA-Vermutung nicht mehr. Die besagt, dass die GEMA eben ein weltweites Musikrepertoire vertritt. Und wer meint, sie würde das nicht vertreten, hat die Beweislast, wie wir gerade gehört haben, dafür, dass das nicht der Fall ist. Nun gibt es diese Initiative C3S, weil im Urheberrecht ja doch einiges festgefahren ist. Die GEMA gibt es schon sehr lange. Und weil es technische Veränderungen gegeben hat. Und aufgrund dieser technischen Veränderungen sich auch viel geändert hat bei den Lizenzen. Wir haben die Creative Commons Lizenzen, die es früher nicht gab, als die GEMA gegründet wurde. Und die werden von der GEMA nicht wahrgenommen. Deswegen gibt es viele Urheber, die sagen, wir möchten gerne eine Verwertungsgesellschaft haben, die zu unseren Bedingungen unsere Lizenzen verwaltet und wahrnimmt. Und das war so der Anstoß für die C3S eigentlich. Die C3S ist eine Initiative von Urhebern, von Künstlern und eben auch Beratern, sind auch mehrere Anwälte dabei, die diese Initiative beraten. Und die möchte nun eine solche Wahrnehmungsgesellschaft gründen, wie das im Gesetz heißt. Also das machen, was die GEMA macht. Sie möchte das gleich aber von Anfang an auf europäischer Ebene machen, in der Rechtsform einer europäischen Genossenschaft. Und der Kerngedanke dabei ist, dass diese Gesellschaft ein reiner Dienstleister für die Urheber ist. Also dazu da ist, den erstens vernünftige Verwertungsmöglichkeiten zu bieten, für ihre Werke ihnen aber auch die Möglichkeit zu geben, halt, das will ich kostenlos zur Verfügung stellen. Ich will zum Beispiel, dass die Privatkopie wieder möglich ist. Dafür will ich keine Nutzungsgebühr haben. Damit würden die Abmahnwellen im Wesentlichen aufhören. Das ist so der Grundgedanke, der bei der C3S dahinter ist. Und das zu verwirklichen, erfordert viel Arbeit noch.
Das wollte ich gerade fragen. Ich habe vor zwei oder drei Jahren zum ersten Mal mit Mike Michalke gesprochen. Auch ein treibender Mann hinter diesem ganzen Projekt. Seitdem warte ich eigentlich immer darauf, dass es nun mal losgeht. Jetzt ist 2012 fast schon wieder vorbei. Es hat immer noch nicht geklappt. Geht es jetzt demnächst los?
Ja, jetzt geht es demnächst los. Wir waren im November beim Deutschen Patent- und Markenamt. Das ist die Behörde, die solch eine Wahrnehmungsgesellschaft zulassen muss. Denn es darf nicht jeder einfach sagen, ich kassehe jetzt für alle Urheber. Sondern er braucht dazu eine behördliche Genehmigung zum Schutz der Urheber, damit eben nicht jeder herkommen kann und nachher mit dem Geld vielleicht sogar abhaut. Man muss nachweisen, dass das eigene Modell wirtschaftlich tragfähig ist, dass die Leute, die die Gesellschaft betreiben, dass die zuverlässig sind in persönlicher Hinsicht. Und dann werden die anderen Urhebergesellschaften auch dazu gehört. Und das ganze Verfahren wird möglicherweise ein halbes oder ein Jahr dauern, bis die Zulassung da ist. Aber erste Voraussetzung ist, dass überhaupt diese Gesellschaft gegründet ist. Das soll ja eine europäische Genossenschaft sein. Dazu muss man genügend Urheber dann finden, die auch Geld einzahlen und das Kapital zusammenkriegen, um die Gesellschaft dann auch auf einer wirtschaftlich tragfähigen Basis betreiben zu können.
An dem Punkt sind wir jetzt aber, sagst du schon...
An dem Punkt sind wir, dass wir jetzt sammeln. Es gibt Absichtserklärungen auf der Webseite c3s.cc. Da kann man Mitglied werden, und zwar für kleines Geld, 50 Euro. Man kann gerne auch mehr Anteile erwärmen.
Aber wie weit seid ihr da jetzt schon? Wie viel Künstler braucht ihr und wie viel habt ihr schon?
Wie viele Künstler wir brauchen? Wir brauchen 30.000 Euro, um die Gesellschaft eingetragen zu kriegen. Das muss nicht nur von Künstlern kommen. Es können auch gerne investierende Mitglieder größere Beträge einzahlen. Nur wir wollten es für die Künstler offen halten und sagen, 50 Euro muss reichen. Und dann habt ihr einen Anteil und dann habt ihr auch eine Stimme.
Und wie weit seid ihr da schon?
wie viele Absichtserklärungen da reingesteckt sind.
Man weiß es noch nicht so genau. Aber heißt es, ich kann dich jetzt darauf festlagen, 2013 wird es die C3S geben?
Ja. Wir wollten eigentlich im Januar 2013 den Zulassungsantrag schon stellen. Das dauert vielleicht noch mal einen Monat länger. Weil wir nämlich auch überlegen müssen, wie wir die Musikverleger einbinden. Viele Künstler haben ja mit einem Verleger einen Vertrag gemacht. Das kann ja auch wirtschaftlich sinnvoll sein. Man will sich um den Krams nicht kümmern.
Genau. Also zum Verständnis, der Künstler macht da nur die Musik und der Verleger kümmert sich dann halt darum, dass das alles... Darum, dass er verbreitet wird.
Das ist ja auch ein sinnvoller Job. Der macht das Marketing dafür und kriegt was dafür. Und der muss ja irgendwie in so eine Verwertungsgesellschaft auch eingebunden sein, denn der kassiert dann ja auch. Und da ist die Diskussion, ob wir die als investierende Mitglieder reinnehmen oder ob wir für die einen Beirat machen, was das Gesetz mindestens fordert. Wenn die nicht Mitglieder werden können, dann müssen die in einen Beirat integriert werden, damit die auch gehört werden und deren Interessen wahrgenommen werden. Das ist etwas, was wir an der Satzung noch überlegen müssen. Wir wollen aber in jedem Fall als Mitglieder, als Kernmitgliedschaft, nur die tatsächlichen Urheber haben.
Okay, also da geht es noch um juristische Formalien. Aber ich halte mal fest, nächstes Jahr um diese Zeit sprechen wir schon mit einem Vertreter der bereits existierenden Verwertungsrechteorganisation C3S und wir haben in Deutschland keine GEMA-Vermutung mehr.
Drückt uns die Daumen bitte.
Alles klar, machen wir. Mein Herr Czarostik hat uns das gerade alles erklärt und zwar sehr verständlich. Dafür vielen Dank und viel Glück. Und wie gesagt, auf mich sprechen wir uns nächstes Jahr dann als Vertreter.
Ja, herzlich gerne.
Warte, eine Frage hab ich noch. Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass die GEMA das irgendwie alles nicht so richtig prall findet. Habt ihr da mal versucht dagegen zu schießen? Irgendwie juristisch oder finanziell oder?
Das interessiert mich, das wollte ich aber auch gerade fragen, ob es da irgendwie... Inwiefern leidet jetzt die GEMA da drunter?
Ja, also die GEMA leidet ja sowieso. Die haben Einnahmen und Rückgänge, auch die GVL. Das ist das Gegenstück, das die Verwertungswirtschaft, die Leistungsschutzrechte wahrnimmt. Also jedes Mal, wenn Musik im Radio zum Beispiel gespielt wird, kassiert die GVL für die Künstler und für die Labels. Die haben derbe Umsatzrückgänge, aber wir verstehen uns ja nicht als Konkurrenz zur GEMA. Die Creative Commons Lizenzen werden von der GEMA gar nicht wahrgenommen. Wir verstehen uns als echte Alternative. Natürlich wird es Überschneidungen und Konkurrenzen geben, aber wir sind eigentlich darauf gepolt, mit der GEMA zu reden und zum Beispiel das Repertoire aufzunehmen. Damit wir vernünftig abrechnen können, muss ja jedes Musikstück erst mal einen Code kriegen, damit man die überhaupt erfassen kann.
Und hat die GEMA sich da schon irgendwie geäußert, wie die da mit Ihnen zusammenarbeiten möchte?
Nein, wir sind bisher in Vorgesprächen. Das sind bisher nur deswegen Vorgespräche, weil es gibt die C3S juristisch ja noch nicht.
Okay, dann würde ich sagen, nochmal hart. Ich beneide mich nicht um den Job. Ich finde es gut, dass es passiert, aber ich möchte den Job tatsächlich nicht selber machen. Aber dabei nochmal viel Glück und vielen Dank nochmal.
Ja, vielen Dank meinerseits.
So, da hätten wir also das mit der Musik geklärt.
Und demnächst gibt es dann auf YouTube wieder weniger GEMA fressen. Wenn man die Musik hören möchte, die man gerade mal hören möchte, wäre das nicht toll?
Das wäre, also ich weiß nicht, ob der Zusammenhang da sozusagen tatsächlich so besteht und dann wirklich klappt. Aber wir wollen die Hoffnung nicht aufgeben. Jetzt gibt es ja beim Urheberrecht noch eine andere Seite. Das ist ja die nicht mit der Musik im Internet, sondern die mit dem Texten im Internet. Wir haben ja das Leistungsschutzrecht, weil jetzt auch in den Tagen Schlagzeilen ist heute glaube ich verhandelt worden oder wird morgen?
Es wird um 00.15 Uhr oder so.
Ach ja, doch so früh, natürlich. Aber immerhin mit Redezeit. Also nochmal von vorne, Leistungsschutzrecht. Wer von euch mag es erklären? Also das Leistungsschutzrecht, ja bitte.
Das Leistungsschutzrecht ist ein Konstrukt, in der die Verleger irgendwie ein Stückchen von dem Kuchen abhaben wollen, den sie selber gefühlt an Google verschenken, indem sie dort bei Google die Snippets hinterlassen und würden dann Aggregatoren, und meinen da eigentlich in allererster Linie Google, dann finanziell mal bluten lassen für alles, was man dort in seinen Aggregatorseiten...
So wie du sagst, klingt das so, ja Google verwendet Textbostellen, aber es geht darum, Überschriften von Artikeln, die den Link zum Artikel kennzeichnen. Dafür soll Geld bezahlt werden.
Na, das ist ja noch ein bisschen weitergefasst, es müssen ja nicht mal ganz so Überschriften sein, es reichen da schon prägnante Passagen aus den Überschriften heraus. Aber eigentlich geht es darum, eine Weiterverwertung von auch kleinsten Textbausteinen einfach prinzipiell verlegeln, die Möglichkeit zu geben, dass die sich dann bei jedem bedienen, der es irgendwie zitiert.
Meine Lieblingsstelle an der Sache ist ja, die haben ja gesagt, ok, Google will unsere Texte verlinken, dafür soll es Gebühren geben. Dann sagt Google, ach wisst ihr Leute, dann nehmen wir eure Sachen einfach nicht mehr in die Suchmaschine auf, weil kostet ja Geld, wollen wir nicht zahlen. Und dann sagen die Verleger, ja, aber das wäre ja auch nur zu der Monopol-Telle. Da muss der Gesetzgeber doch sagen, Google ist dazu verpflichtet, die Artikel aufzunehmen und damit ist quasi Google dann gesetzlich verpflichtet, Gebühren an die Presseverleger zu zahlen. Ich finde das tapfer. Auch schon irgendwie bewundernswert.
Ja, eine Dreistigkeit, die...
Ja, könnte man so sagen. Übrigens, am 6. Dezember, Christoph Käse gegen Kai Oberbeck. Christoph Käse muss man wissen, das ist von Axel Springer, wird sozusagen von Stefan Niggemeier gerne der Botschafter von Axel Springer genannt. Kai Oberbeck ist von Google. Und die sind zusammen bei einer Podiumsdiskussion in Berlin. Das könnte spannend werden oder sie labern die ganze Zeit, man weiß es nicht.
Aber was heute Abend an dieser Verhandlung so spannend ist, ist, dass die Opposition will da komplett anrücken. Und zwar zu dieser unchristlichen Stunde. Und wollen auch alle was dazu sagen. Ist ja ihr gutes Recht. Und wenn jetzt nicht die Regierung auch vollständig da antanzt, dann wird das einfach gekippt. Die Mutti will ja unbedingt, dass dieses Gesetz durchgeht. Die hat auch noch mal schon letztendlich in der New York Times stand drin, dass sie rumgefragt hat bei ihren Ministern und Abgeordneten, wie viel Mails sie so dann bekommen hätten zu diesem Thema. Und nachdem dann, ja so 10, 11. Ja gut, dann machen wir das, dann wollen wir das. Und dann werden die sich da heute Abend wahrscheinlich dann noch mal alle in echt fröhlicher Runde am Bundestag versammeln müssen, um das zu besprechen.
Was ja auch schon wieder so eine geile Apropos Jahresprodukt, wie funktioniert Politik? Da hat man auch da schon wieder sehr schön gesehen, das Leistungsschutzrecht hat so funktioniert, dass sie das spät in der Nacht auf die Tagesordnung der Bundestagssitzung packen wollten. Und zwar so spät, dass da nicht mehr zu geredet wird, sondern dass die Redebeiträge in Anführungszeichen Redebeiträge in Textform abgegeben werden. Und nur weil es in der letzten Woche Aufregung im Netz gab, haben sie dann gesagt, ja gut, wir sprechen wirklich drüber.
Ja, aber es kam heute, dass genau alle Jugendorganisationen aller Parteien gemeint haben, das ist ein großer Käse. Das wollen wir nicht, sogar die junge Union. Also wenn sogar die junge Union...
Was hast du gesagt, ich muss mich hier neutral verhalten?
Wenn sogar die junge Union da laut gegen stürmt und kein Problem mit den jungen Liberalen, mit den jungen Piraten, mit der Jugendorganisation der Grünen. Also gut, die Linken hatten auch was dagegen, aber da wollte die junge Union nicht mit denen... Aber wenn selbst die junge Union da was dagegen gesagt hat, dann weißt du, dass dein Gesetz eigentlich...
Aber jetzt habe ich aber heute gelesen, dass das Leutegebiet gehen davon aus, das wird nicht mehr verändert. Das wird auf jeden Fall kommen, glaubt ihr das auch?
Nein, ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen. Denn wenn das Gesetz kommt, dann ist das wirklich das Aus für die deutschen Verlage. Denn Google wird das nicht zahlen. Die nehmen einfach dann alle deutschen Presseprodukte aus ihrem Superindex-Radar.
Also es gibt in Frankreich hat Google angekündigt, nicht alle Presseprodukte, sondern alle französisch-sprachigen Texte. Weil man kann sich ja nie sicher sein, dass nicht dahinter sozusagen ein Rechteverwerter steht.
Genau, das ist ja der Punkt. Also es werden dann auch alle deutschsprachigen Texte verschwinden aus dem Netz. Nun wissen wir ja schon von der Wikipedia, dass die englische Wikipedia diejenigen ist, die man eigentlich nutzen will. Aber es wird dann auch so sein, dass man überhaupt keine deutschen Texte mehr nutzen kann oder auch vielleicht nicht mehr nutzen will, weil mit Deutsch wird man nicht mehr gefunden.
In 200 Jahren gibt es so eine Geschichte, die steht, wie Englisch zur Weltsprache wurde.
Aber es ist schön zu sehen, dass Google das erste Mal richtig die Kampagnenfaust geballt hat. Haben sie sich ja vorher echt zurückgehalten in Deutschland. Sie haben damals einmal diese Netzzensur zur SOPA da rausgeholt und dann die ganzen Kampagnenfausten geballt. Aber wenn du dir überlegst, wie viele Eyeballs Google am Tag hat und die da alle in so einer Kampagne zu fokussieren.
Wobei ich das schon sehr spannend fand, weil das ist ja seit vorgestern, dass Google auf der Startseite sozusagen gelingt hat, verteidigt euer Netz. Und da geht es halt genau darum. Und die Reflexe, die losging, waren so, Moment mal, Google ist doch auch nur eine große Firma, die Angst um ihre Kohle haben. Also da musste man schon mal erklären, dass diese große Firma möglicherweise das ist, was die Aktivisten auch wollen. Das ist tatsächlich nicht mehr selbstverständlich. Das fand ich schon beeindruckend.
Na bloß, das ist ja nun nicht so binär, dass automatisch der Fand meines Feindes mein Freund ist.
Ja, ich meine nur sozusagen bei größeren Teilen, die sich nicht mit diesem Thema beschäftigen, also die nicht sofort den Durchblick haben und sagen, also Google mit den Daten, das ist die eine Geschichte, aber Leistungsschutzrecht wollen wir alle nicht. Das heißt, wenn Google dagegen eine Kampagne macht, das ist auch mal gut.
Aber ich finde es trotzdem spannend, sich das so zu überlegen, was dafür auch eine mediale Macht. Einfach dazu sagen, dass Google dann an der Stelle kein verlegerähnliches Konstrukt ist, ist dann auch sehr gewagt. Weil die haben Murdoch-Style-Kampagnenfähigkeit jetzt mal bewiesen. Mit SOPA haben sie das erste Mal in Amerika gezeigt, dass, wenn sie nicht wollen, dass die Leute alle den Schwanz einziehen. Und in Deutschland werden wir mal gucken, was da jetzt rauskommt.
Möglicherweise Google verstaatlichen?
Spannend bis gefährlich. Das ist ja das, was die Verleger ungefähr wollen.
Welcher Staat verstaht durch den Google? Das ist auch ein Problem, würde ich sagen.
Dann gibt es bestimmt ein Forschungsprojekt von der Europäischen Union zur Entwicklung einer eigenen Suchmaschine, die total erfolgreich sein oder vielleicht auch nicht. Egal. Das ist Galileo wahrscheinlich. Jetzt haben wir ja sozusagen Urheberrecht, die großen Sachen, Musik, weiß sofort jeder, weil der Freund eines Freundes ist dann auch irgendwie abgemeint worden. Leistungsschutzrecht ist man zumindest schon länger informiert, wenn man sich für diese Netzthemen interessiert. Und ist man auch darüber gestolpert, wenn man jetzt irgendwie News liest, weil das wirklich, wirklich groß wird langsam. Ich zähle jetzt Musik und filme mal unter Medienerzeugnisse, die durchs Netz wandern.
Da sind wir jetzt mit mega auch spannende Entwicklung noch am Amt kommen. Also nicht, dass es Kimbell gönnen, aber wenn man sich da überlegt, dass wenn der da unten so ein Produkt mal aufzieht, mit verschlüsseltem Storage für alle und das irgendwie einigermaßen benutzerfreundlich und sexy macht und dann garantieren kann, wir können da nicht mal reingucken, keiner sonst reingucken, dann könnte das funktionieren. Ich gönn's ihm einfach nicht, aber es ist irgendwie, er wird dann gewinnen.
Da müsste man, jahresbrücklich würde ich noch mal einen Schritt zurückgehen wollen und sagen, 2012, das Ende der Share-Hoster. Also Rapid Share, Mega Upload, wie die alle hießen, wurden ja durch diese große Aktion, genau gegen Mega Upload, wo Kimbell halt der Chef war sozusagen eingeleitet und mittlerweile ist das so ein bisschen raus. Es gibt zwar diese ganzen Sachen noch, aber es funktioniert nicht mehr so groß und so gut, wie es mal war. Und jetzt hat der Kimbell gesagt, so, pass mal auf, Neuseeland ist es, pass mal auf Neuseeland, ich leg dir eine fette Glasfaserleitung vom Festplatz hin. Dafür mach ich die Firma bei mir auf und dann machen wir mal noch mal so ein File Sharing Dienst, also File Hosting Dienst. Und das wird dann alles noch mit verschlüsselt und viel besser und überhaupt. Jetzt würde ich aber nochmal weg von Filmen, Musik und Leistungsschutzrechten. Hat der Maha noch eine Sache mitgebracht, die in so einer Ecke ist, die total wichtig ist für die Gesellschaft, glaube ich, aber die kaum jemand auf dem Schirm hat.
Ja, also es ist die Geschichte mit dem Paragraph 52a des Urheberrechts. Da ist geregelt, dass in der Wissenschaft und in Schulen eben auf internen Servern Material vorgehalten werden kann. Also für die Schüler bzw. für die Studenten. Und diese Erlaubnis, diese Ausnahme, also sogenannte Schranke des Urheberrechts, ist befristet bis zum 31.12.2012. Also bald wird das nicht mehr möglich sein. Nun haben alle Schulen natürlich so ein Intranet mit Servern und Unis sowieso, wo halt auch das Material drauf liegt, was man unbedingt braucht, um sein Examen vorzubereiten. Und das soll eigentlich alles zum 1. Januar 2013 abgeschafft werden, wenn diese Regelung nicht verlängert wird. Und das ist im Augenblick im Gespräch. Und vielleicht wird diese Nacht ja noch eine Verlängerung entschieden.
Also wird heute auch in dieser Bundestagssitzung?
Möglicherweise, ja. Der Gesetzentwurf für die Verlängerung liegt vor. Und das soll eben jetzt auch verhandelt werden.
Wie ist da die Stimmung so?
Die Stimmung ist so, dass CDU, CSU und FDP tatsächlich diese Verlängerung wollen bis 2014. Was natürlich immer noch eine Krücke ist. Denn eigentlich sollte sowas selbstverständlich sein. Und es sollte eigentlich auch noch viel mehr geben. Denn was nützt das, wenn irgendwelche Profs ihre Vorlesungen auf internen Servern bereitstellen? Die sollen natürlich öffentlich sein und auf iTunes U oder auch auf irgendwelchen anderen Plattformen zur Verfügung stehen. Und nicht auf irgendwelchen geschlossenen Benutzerplattformen sein. Aber selbst das soll eben ab dem 1. Januar nicht mehr möglich sein, wenn das Gesetz nicht verlängert wird.
Und das Gesetz, wenn das verlängert wird, heißt das sagen, es gibt dann wieder eine Frist, die abläuft?
Genau, bis 2014.
Gibt es dann nicht mal irgendwie die Bestrebung, dass man sagt, okay Leute, wir brauchen mal, sagen wir mal, fristlos ist ja immer so schön gesagt, aber tatsächlich erstmal eine unbefristete Regelung?
Ja, das bräuchte man eigentlich, aber das will irgendwie keiner. Der Druck vom Börsenverein des Buchhandels ist da irgendwie sehr hoch. Und die derzeitige Regierung will nicht einfach sagen, ach ja, das soll jetzt immer so sein. Die sind da eben unter Druck von Lobbyisten, wie man deutlich merkt. Und deshalb immer diese vorsichtige Regelung, also noch mal zwei Jahre verlängern.
Was sollten sie eigentlich mal mit allen Gesetzen machen? So gleich verfall das Datum ran, dass irgendwie so dieser ganze Gesetzeskraft, der nicht regelmäßig wieder...
Weiß ich nicht, ob man sich da nicht irgendwie was einhält. Also klar, für die einen Sachen ist es gut, dass sie immer wieder auf den Prüfstand kommt. Aber bei den anderen ist es natürlich jedes Mal, wenn ein Gesetz da ist, was halt gut ist, und dann wird es alle zwei Jahre wieder neu verhandelt. Ich weiß nicht, ob man sich da nicht was einhandelt. Was eintritt quasi. Also so, stell dir vor, Netzneutralität. Und in zwei Jahren kommen sie wieder an und sagen so naja, nö, brauchen wir jetzt ein Jahr.
Und überhaupt nicht.
Auch ein spannendes Thema, können wir vielleicht gleich noch drüber reden. Jetzt machen wir erst mal das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr und danach geht's noch ein bisschen um Politik. Dann reden wir nämlich über ein transparentes Gesetz. Wenn das die Leute sehen könnten, die hier für die Technik verantwortlich sind. Da stehen Getränke im Studio. Das kann nur eins bedeuten, das ist Chaos Radio. Einmal Monat kommt der Chaos Computer Club her. Heute geht es nicht um ein Einzelthema, sondern um einen Jahresrückblick auf 2012. Wir haben gerade schon im Eildurchmarsch über die verschiedenen Urheberrechtsprobleme gesprochen, die wir haben und die daraus resultieren, dass die Technik ein bisschen weiter ist als viele andere Leute. Zu Gast sind Erdgeist, THS und Maha. Hallo nochmal. Maha ist ja jemand, der sich auch mit Sprech beschäftigt. Er nennt es manchmal Neussprech, ich nenne es gerne Politikersprech. In dieser Urheberrechtsdebatte gibt es da eine bestimmte Verschleierungstaktiken, die gerne verwendet werden?
Ja, wir sehen das ja schon bei so einem Wort wie Leistungsschutzrecht. Es wird immer geschützt, wenn man es genau nimmt. Es wird alles geschützt. Wir hatten das ja vorhin schon bei der GEMA-Vermutung. Die Musik ist geschützt. Aber es bedeutet in letzter Konsequenz, dass man sie gar nicht nutzen kann, dass sie sozusagen von den Nutzern geschützt wird. Das ist ja eigentlich schon irgendwie die verkehrte Welt.
Na gut, meinst du, wir kommen aus dem Schutz irgendwann raus?
Ja, ich hoffe schon.
Schauen wir mal, haben wir ja nächstes Jahr noch viel Zeit. Was es dieses Jahr auch gab, ist an der politischen Ebene eine sehr spannende Entwicklung. Und zwar gibt es in Hamburg jetzt ein sogenanntes Transparenzgesetz. Und dass es das gibt, ist auf eine besonders, ja, Leistung, muss ich sagen, zurückzuführen, von jemand. Nee, nicht von jemand, sondern von einer Gruppe von Leuten. Aber da hat auch jemand mitgearbeitet, der auch im Club ist. Und dieser jemand heißt Dodger und ist wie gesagt im Club in Hamburg und ist jetzt am Telefon. Hallo und guten Abend. So, noch mal Transparenzgesetz und wie es dazu kam in Hamburg in zwei Minuten.
In zwei Minuten? Es gab eine Volksinitiative aus mehr Demokratie, Transparency International und dem Club. Und die kam auf die Idee, wir brauchen mehr Informationen. Das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz reicht nicht. Und daraufhin hat man sich hingesetzt. Und wir haben dann gemeinsam in einem Wiki im Internet ein Gesetz geschrieben, haben das anschließend von Juristen prüfen lassen und haben das dann über eine Volksinitiative eingereicht. Und haben das nach einem Jahr ohne in eine große Unterschriftensammlung zu gehen durch die Politik durchbekommen. Und das ist seit dem 6. Oktober in Kraft in Hamburg.
Und was genau kann man jetzt mit diesem Transparenzgesetz machen?
Der Grundansatz ist der, dass alle Informationen, die mit Steuergeldern bezahlt sind, im Endeffekt auch für die Bürger, die sie ja bezahlt haben, frei sein sollen. Das heißt, ich kann also in Zukunft, das ist jetzt im Moment im Werden, in zwei Jahren wird das fertig sein, im Internet in einen Informationsregister gehen und kann mir alle Informationen, die mich irgendwo betreffen, sprich, was passiert mit der Brachfläche auf der anderen Straßenseite, wird da gebaut, oder was passiert mit diesen Schlaglöchern an der Straße, oder aber auch, was für ein Gehalt bekommen die Manager der Stadt oder landeseigenen Konzerne, etc. Solche Informationen kann ich mir dann da abrufen.
Jetzt habt ihr das durchgesetzt durch eine Bürgerinitiative. Es gibt jetzt dieses Gesetz. Gibt es da schon auch erste Ergebnisse? Also sind da schon Anfragen jetzt durchgegangen?
Na, es gibt schon Anfragen. Wir haben natürlich hier in Hamburg den großen Aufreger, die Elbphilharmonie. Da hat man auch bundesweit glaube ich von gehört, so ein Milliardengrab und Bauruine im Moment. Und das war die erste Anfrage, die wir da reingekippt haben, ungefähr drei Minuten nachdem das Gesetz in Kraft getreten ist. Und die Jungs von Frag den Staat haben dankenswerterweise ihr Portal erweitert. Das heißt, das gibt jetzt Frag den Staat Hamburg. Da kann man sehr einfach Anfragen erstellen, die dann direkt in die Verwaltung gehen. Und da gibt es schon mittlerweile einige, ich habe jetzt zwei, drei Tage nicht mehr drauf geguckt, aber bestimmt 50, 60 Anfragen gibt es da schon. Und da ist die Verwaltung jetzt gerade fleißig bemüht, sie zu beantworten.
Gibt aber sozusagen noch nichts, was man an Ergebnis und Vorweisen kann?
Ja, das ist natürlich jetzt der Punkt, dass zuerst natürlich die großen Brocken da reingefallen sind. Also solche Sachen wie die Elbphilharmonie. Dann wurden hier in Hamburg die Stromnetze privatisiert, ähnlich wie in Berlin die Wasserwerke. Da will man die Verträge sehen. Und also alles solche Sachen, die schon seit Monaten und Jahren in der Schwebe sind. Und bei solchen Altverträgen hat die Stadt halt den Auftrag jetzt und haben sechs Monate Zeit, da nachzuverhandeln und irgendwelche Geheimhaltungsklauseln aus den Verträgen herauszuverhandeln. Da müssen wir denen also ein bisschen Zeit lassen. Da kommt also jetzt nach und nach kommen da die Antworten rein.
Jetzt ist es ja beim Transparenzgesetz so, ihr habt ja ein schönes Druckmittel. Denn in Hamburg ist es so, wenn man eine bestimmte Anzahl von Stimmen sammelt, also eine ganze Bevölkerung, dann wird so etwas gleichgesetzt. Und das sozusagen, also die Gefahr dessen hat möglicherweise die Politik dazu animiert, dann möglicherweise schon vorher drüber nachzudenken. Jetzt ist es ja so, anders von Deutschland funktioniert das nicht, aber so ein Transparenzgesetz wollen natürlich trotzdem vielleicht noch ein paar mehr Leute haben. Habt ihr da Anfragen bekommen? Gibt es da Pläne, das irgendwie auszuweiten?
Ja, also auf jeden Fall. Sowohl in NRW, da gibt es eine relativ starke Bürgerbewegung, auch über mehr Demokratie, die da dran ist. Im Saarland gibt es Bestrebungen, in Berlin gibt es auch Bestrebungen. Leider hat sich das bewahrheitet, was wir hier vermieden haben, nämlich, dass die Parteien von vornherein mit dem Boot sind. Wir haben es also erstmal mit NGOs gestartet. In Berlin gibt es im Moment einen riesen Streit zwischen den Grünen und den Piraten. Wer es denn jetzt erfunden hat?
Oh, das ist natürlich total wichtig, diesmal da rum zu streiten.
Genau, und das ist natürlich ein bisschen blöd, weil da sollte man vielleicht einfach mal die Gräben überwinden und inhaltlich zusammenarbeiten. Das hat hier super funktioniert. Hier waren auch die Grünen und die Piraten mit im Bündnis dann später als Partner. Und es hat eigentlich immer super geklappt in der Zusammenarbeit. Und vielleicht können sich die Berliner da mal ein bisschen am Riemen reißen.
Na, habt ihr gehört, Berliner, reißt euch mal am Riemen hier. Hast du denn was in der Aussicht? Also glaubst du, da geht noch mehr im nächsten Jahr? Oder wird das sozusagen in den anderen Versanden, weil in den anderen Ländern, weil die da das Druckmittel nicht haben, dieses so? Na, im Zweifelsfall lassen wir halt die Bevölkerung entscheiden.
Na, ich denke mal, da wir ja auf eine Bundestagswahl zulaufen und das Thema Transparenz ja auch in der Bundespolitik relativ hochkocht oder immer wieder aufkommt, wird es da unter Umständen im Bezug auf die Bundestagswahl doch die eine oder andere Bereitschaft geben. Aber was da jetzt konkret in den Ländern passiert, muss man abwarten. Jetzt sagen wir natürlich auch hier aus Hamburg, wir wollen uns nicht in jedem Bundesland hinstellen und denen vormachen, wie das geht, zumal ja jede Landesregierung oder jedes Land eigene Gesetze hat. Das müssen die schon selber machen, wir können halt nur beraten. Also ich hab ehrlich gesagt nicht vor die nächsten 12 Jahre durch Deutschland zu reisen. Was?
Ich dachte du machst so einen tingelnden Betrieb auf Transparenz auch unterwegs.
Ach nö, ich hab noch andere Hobbys.
Na gut, aber ihr könnt ja in Deutschland ein Beispiel nehmen, er war mit dabei beim Transparenzgesetz in Hamburg und möglicherweise gibt es das ja auch bald woanders. Dodger, vielen Dank und viel Spaß dann bei deinen anderen Hobbys.
Einen schönen Abend noch.
So, das geht ja hier wie das Brezelbacken heute. Jetzt frage ich mich ja, wollen wir jetzt weitermachen mit Politik oder wollen wir mal so ein bisschen in Extremschwenk machen, wie die Werte rundig im Radio?
Wetter und Verkehr?
Nein, dazu kommen wir später möglicherweise. Was ich ein interessantes Thema fand, was sich so um die Ecke in meinen Hirn drängte in der Vorbesprechung dieser Sendung, ist eins, das liegt mir sehr am Herzen, aber das hat mir erst gar nicht auf dem Schirm. Da geht es um Telefone. Und deswegen ist ja der THS auch hier, glaube ich, oder?
Naja, ich bin eigentlich nur hier zum Autofahren.
Ja, aber du hast auch so ein paar Dinge gesagt, die ich deshalb so interessant fand, weil, also wenn nicht schon 2011 ist dieses Jahr, also würde ich natürlich sagen, so das Jahr der Smartphones, in dem Sinne, dass immer mehr Leute so ein Ding haben, dass es immer mehr der Computer ist, den Leute am meisten nutzen und dem aber viel weniger, ja wie soll man das sagen, ein Gefühl dafür existiert, dass das ja auch so eine Rechenmaschine ist, die angreifbar ist, die vielleicht sicher gestaltet sein sollte. Also diese ganzen Gedanken, die man sich bei Rechnern macht, also da ist ja so, also wie ein Scanner und Firewall auch, wenn manche Leute sagen, das bringt alles sowieso nichts, aber zumindest haben die Leute es schon mal gehört, also das Konzept von Sicherheit bei einem Computer ist da, bei Handys scheint das irgendwie gar keine Rolle zu spielen. Warum nicht?
Naja, auf das Thema gekommen sind wir einfach, weil wir überlegt haben, was war in diesem Jahr überhaupt so interessant oder so wichtig und ich habe das halt einfach mal reingeworfen, weil ich persönlich fand das einfach wichtig, weil nicht um jetzt hier irgendwie Werbung zu machen für einen Hersteller, aber Microsoft wollte halt mit ihrem neuen Betriebssystem halt den Markt ein bisschen aufmischen und ich war halt einfach sehr gespannt darauf, denn ich bin sehr frustriert, was auf diesem Markt los ist. Also ich benutze halt irgendwie zwar selber eines dieser Mainstream-Telefone, aber ich bin einfach unzufrieden. Insofern, als dass ich einfach Angst habe, die Dinger, die sind einfach sicherheitstechnisch nicht auf einem Stand, wo ich sage, das ist halt irgendwie ein vernünftiges Niveau, ein vernünftiges Level. Die Hersteller scheinen da auch die Prioritäten anders zu setzen. Es gibt halt Apple, die legen halt sehr viel Wert auf Benutzbarkeit und eine tolle Oberfläche und es gibt halt irgendwie die Business-Telefone von Blackberry und es gibt halt Frickele-Telefone mit Androids. Und ja, ich finde das alles sehr unzufriedenstellend. Ich mag mich halt selber nicht auf eine bestimmte Plattform festlegen. Und deswegen habe ich mich auch ein bisschen gefreut. Okay, jetzt kommt da Microsoft an. Die tun ja nachweislich schon seit ziemlich vielen Jahren ziemlich viel für ihre eigene Sicherheit. Also da kann man halt sagen, was man möchte. Sie sind da aktiv dabei halt auch zu investieren, dass ihre ganzen Produkte ein bisschen sicherer werden. Und ich dachte, ich habe mir dafür von versprochen und habe mich ein bisschen darauf gefreut, dass es endlich jemanden gibt, der vielleicht mal neue Maßstäbe setzt. Und? Nun kam halt dieses Microsoft Windows Phone 8 endlich mal auf dem Markt auf einem Nokia-Telefon. Und ich habe es mir dann halt auch mal angeguckt, weil ich halt einfach wirklich, ich habe echt gehofft, dass Microsoft in der Lage ist, mal diesen guten, diesen Mittelweg zu finden zwischen guter Benutzbarkeit und schöner Benutzeroberfläche und Sicherheit und einfach so ein bisschen das vereint von einem iPhone und von so einem Blackberry. Ich meine, ich benutze halt ein Telefon heutzutage auch anders als vor fünf oder sechs Jahren. Ich bin halt auch viel unterwegs. Ich brauche halt vernünftige Anwendungen, mit denen ich halt irgendwie meinen ganzen Geschäftsablauf auch ein bisschen durchorganisieren kann und alles. Und das ist halt, ja, zum Beispiel so ein iPhone bietet mir halt auch so ein IPSEC wie PN.
Das ist halt nicht ein Ding, mit dem man sicher kommunizieren kann.
Das erlaubt mir halt einfach auf eine sehr einfache und Art und Weise eben eine sichere Verbindung zu Systemen zu öffnen, die ich halt so nicht frei im Internet verfügbar stehen habe, weil sie eben einfach auch sensible Daten beinhalten. Zum Beispiel eben so ein Kalender und ich tue halt nicht meine Daten in irgendeine Cloud. Also jeder Anbieter hat heutzutage noch irgendeinen Cloud-Service. Also da hat Apple halt ihre Apple Cloud und Microsoft hat ja auch ihre Cloud und Google hat natürlich eine Cloud. Und alles, was du da an Businessdaten hast, soll da halt sofort hin. Apple sind sogar die einzigen, die irgendwie noch ein ein anständiges Backup-Konzept vorzulegen haben, wenn ich mir irgendwie so ein Google-Phone angucke. Die einzige Möglichkeit sein Telefon zu back-upen ist halt irgendwie alles in die Cloud zu schieben. Und ich finde das halt einfach wirklich eine Frechheit. Und daher habe ich gehofft, dass Microsoft, die ja jetzt sieben Jahre quasi untätig von oben auf diesen Markt herabgeschaut haben, habe ich einfach gehofft, dass die in diesen sieben Jahren einfach aus den Fehlern der anderen gelernt haben und endlich ein Telefon auf den Markt bringen, was sich von jeder Plattform so das Beste runternimmt. Und irgendwie, naja.
Man muss ja aber auch da Zunge zergehen lassen, dass Microsoft jetzt nicht unbedingt den Ruf haben, die Sicherheit erfunden zu haben, dass das sozusagen die Hoffnung möglicherweise sein kann. Ich muss nochmal nachfragen, du beschäftigst dich ja auch ganz viel mit Sicherheit. Ist der Anspruch, den du hast, besonders hoch? Oder ist es einfach so, dass das Smartphones generell, also auch für normalen Menschen, sehr unsicher sind, aber es einfach keiner weiß, weil sozusagen nicht kommuniziert wird?
Ich glaube, meine Ansprüche sind schon relativ hoch, aber ich finde auch, dass auch Otto Normal User durchaus höhere Ansprüche an die Sicherheit seiner eigenen Daten stellen kann. Also, ich meine, jeder sollte sich mal fragen, ob es halt einfach so sinnvoll ist, irgendwie sämtliche privaten Daten in irgendeine Cloud reinzustecken. Also irgendwo muss es halt auch einfach Grenzen geben. Und ich hoffe halt einfach, dass die Hersteller von Betriebssystemen und Software sich auch so ein bisschen in der Pflicht sehen, dem Benutzer ein gewisses Sicherheitsniveau zu bieten und er sich dann da vielleicht wirklich explizit aus diesem Sicherheitsniveau befreien muss, wenn er mit seinen Daten rumsaunen möchte. Jetzt soll er das gerne tun können, aber ich finde, man kann halt schon irgendwie einen höheren Standard ansetzen und ich hatte halt einfach die Hoffnung, dass es eben Microsoft gelingen wird. Ich möchte jetzt hier nicht irgendwie Werbung machen oder sowas. Ich hab mich in meinem... Ich hab schon viele dieser Plattformen angeguckt und ich bin halt echt genau deswegen ja auch so frustriert, weil ich kenne, es gibt halt einfach niemanden, der es wirklich richtig macht.
Ich wollte gerade noch mal fragen, kann man sagen, es gibt jetzt alle großen Player, also wirklich alle haben jetzt ihre eigene Smartphone-Plattform auf dem Markt. Jetzt könnt ihr, also glaubst du, da kommt noch irgendwie so mal Druck, dass sich irgendeiner sich dann unter Druck gesetzt fühlt und sagt, ok, ich will das jetzt auch mal sicher machen und gleichzeitig bedienen wir einfach, weil es das einzige Unterscheidungsmerkmal ist, wo man noch was drehen kann?
Das juckt doch keinen. Ich meine, du musst gucken, selbst wenn du ein toll sicheres Telefon hast, wo Leute darüber nachgedacht haben, wie man die Daten schützen kann, installieren die Leute als allererstes ihren WhatsApp. Und back-upen ihre gesamte Kontaktliste unverschlüsselt übers Internet auf den Server dieser Firma. Ich meine, das ist die Realität da draußen.
Okay, 2012, das Jahr, in dem es normal wurde, dass ein beliebiger Messenger-Dienst auf dein Handy das Adressbuch ausliest und auf irgendeinen Server irgendwo packt. Das hab ich nicht verstanden.
Ein Messenger-Dienst?
Das interessiert überhaupt keinen.
Also das Ding ist sozusagen, mal abgesehen von dem, was technisch gerade passiert, das ist sozusagen total normal geworden. Also ich hab mich ja jetzt sozusagen fürs Programm, fürs Tagesbuch auch häufiger damit beschäftigt, gibt's dann zu diesem WhatsApp-Dienst, der sozusagen nicht nur das Adressbuch überträgt, sondern der so jede Woche eine neue Sicherheitslücke mitbringt, also so wie Microsofts Inter Explorer früher. Und das ist wirklich, wenn man mit Leuten redet, die so eine Dienste benutzen, das ist für die völlig normal, dass das eigene Telefonbuch einfach irgendwo hochgeladen und abgeladen wird. Weil das ist ja dann so schön einfach.
Naja, aber ich mein, da ist ja irgendwas schiefgelaufen, denn ich mein, WhatsApp ist eben der Dienst, mit dem man eben wirklich plattformübergreifend was machen kann. Telekom oder andere Firmen hätten doch auch was plattformübergreifendes machen können. Haben sie aber nicht, weil sie immer mitkassieren wollten. Ich meine, SMS ist ja irgendwie als Cashcow angesehen immer noch, obwohl die Zeit eigentlich völlig vorbei ist. Und wenn niemand was plattformübergreifendes macht, dann darf man sich hinterher nicht wundern, wenn die Leute dann irgendwie...
Aber das hätte ich sagen, das war, WhatsApp war nur die erste. Und das ist immer wieder was ich beobachte. Facebook, ja, so waren groß. Skype, so ein Dienst, auch groß. Alle haben es, deswegen benutzen es alle, egal wie sicher das ist oder nicht. WhatsApp ist jetzt auch so.
Es gibt andere, WhatsApp hat, glaube ich, sogar nochmal eine ganz andere Dimension. Also viel mehr Leute benutzen das eigentlich völlig ohne das Bewusstsein, dass das jetzt irgendwie auch was mit Internet und sozialen Netzen zu tun hat. Und das interessiert sich überhaupt niemand darum, dass die gerade mit so massiven architekturbedingten Sicherheitslücken aufwarten. Also ich meine, das ist auch katastrophal eigentlich im Vergleich, weil du meintest vorhin Internet Explorer und so weiter. Das kannst du, glaube ich, gar nicht vergleichen. Das ist eigentlich richtig krank, was sie da gebaut haben und dass die nicht darauf reagieren. Ich meine, was tun die jetzt? Schweigen die das tot? Was glauben die, dass ich ihre architekturellen...
Natürlich, aber ich meine, du hast doch gesehen, wie lange GSM sich gehalten hat, nachdem dort die Sicherheitslücken bekannt geworden sind.
Ja, GSM gab es nicht wirklich eine Alternative für End-User.
Ich würde mal erst mal darauf warten, was passiert, wenn dann die Einjahresphase vorbei ist, wenn WhatsApp noch kostenlos war und dann die ersten da alle wieder raus stolpern, weil sie doch keine Lust haben, Geld zu bezahlen. Wenn man hat es jetzt ein Jahr benutzt, war es kostenlos, und dann suchen sie sich den nächsten Start-up-Dienst, der ihnen auch kostenlose SMS anbietet.
Noch unsicherer ist es.
Das ist ein weiteres Ding, wo ich gleich mal drüber ranten möchte, aber ich möchte jetzt erstmal Folgendes sagen.
Eure Meinung jetzt anrufen.
0331 70 97 110 Und zwar würde ich mich selbst nicht mehr darum gehen, dass jemand anruft, der WhatsApp immer noch benutzt und erklärt, warum. Wir sind jetzt zwar relativ ausgekreist und mit Schaum von Mut durchs Studio gelaufen, wir sprechen, wir reden ganz zivilisiert mit euch. Mich würde es wirklich mal interessieren. Also sagen, weil aus meiner Perspektive gibt es keinen Grund, diese Dienste zu benutzen. Ich weiß aber, es gibt viele Leute. Das heißt, wenn ihr das macht, ruft mal an und erzählt, warum. Und vielleicht gibt es ja irgendeinen Grund, der total einleuchtend ist. 031 70 97 120. Die andere Sache, die mir in diesem Zusammenhang immer wieder auffällt, ist, dass auch viele Menschen nicht verstehen, dass umsonst nicht so geil ist.
Der Spruch ist, wenn du für irgendeine Dienstleistung nicht bezahlt, dann bist du die Ware und nicht der Kunde. Ich fand, hast du den Fall gesehen von diesem Oxford Dictionary Hersteller, der dort vorgestern, der hatte einen Kopierschutzmodul in seine ziemlich teure iPhone Software eingetan, die im Fall, wenn er denkt, dass er gerade auf einem jailbreakten Telefon installiert wurde, ohne aus dem Upstore runtergeladen zu werden, der dann per Twitter eine Nachricht losschickt, ich bin böser Raubkopierer, ich habe diese Software geklaut und ich überlege mir das jetzt demnächst dreimal. Das Problem war, dass dieses Kopierschutzmodul durch irgendeine komische Situation, wenn sie im falschen Moment das Telefon ausgegangen ist, diese Aktivierung verloren hat und dann einfach losgetwittert hat, so dass mehrere tausend Leute dann gefragt wurden, sag mal, möchtest du ein bisschen mehr Permissions geben, zum Beispiel irgendwie Twitter-Account mitbenutzen? Die meisten Leute haben dann gesagt, ja, und dann haben sie sich tags drauf darüber gewundert, dass für diese 50, 55 Dollar teure Software, die in deren Namen getwittert hat, obwohl sie eigentlich dafür bezahlt haben. Die Antwort der Firma war so ein bisschen, ja naja, irgendwie müssen wir auch unser Geld machen. Alle Leute Raubkopieren unsere Software und ist da wohl verständlich. Die hatten irgendwie keinerlei Schuldbewusstsein, dass sie da sich als die Nutzer ausgeben und dann in deren Namen eigentlich unter falscher Flagge dort Nachrichten verbreitet haben. Ich glaube, in Deutschland ist es sogar justiziabel. Es ist Kreditgefährdung. Also ich glaube, ich hätte in Deutschland mal gleich den da auf die Finger gehauen. Aber das scheint auch total normal, dass man auf einer Applikation, die man gerade aus dem App Store installiert hat und die genau alle Rechte möchte, Kontakte angucken, das Internet Vollzugriff haben, Kamera aktivieren, Mikrofon aktivieren, keine Ahnung, ja, ja. Kann man den nur am Blog alles ausschalten?
Aber das ist Standard, da gewöhnen sich die Leute dran. Ich meine, hast du mal irgendwie so ein Google-Phone angemacht? Ich meine, es ist ja schön und gut, dass man da die Rechte irgendwie vorher sieht, bevor man sich die Anwendung installiert. Aber wenn so eine Anwendung irgendwie mal für sich so einfach mal alle Rechte in Anspruch nimmt, dann wird doch wohl keiner irgendwie sagen, nö, dann installiere ich es halt nicht. Macht halt keiner.
Also ja, im Chat zur Sendung geht es gerade ein bisschen ab, da sagen so Leute, ja, das Problem ist halt, dass es irgendwie Leute, die WhatsApp nutzen, werden kaum Chaosradio hören und umgedreht. Aber sagt der Lars, nee, wer sagt denn das? Irgendjemand hat gesagt, dass die Chaosradiohörer natürlich Leute kennen, die WhatsApp nutzen, da vielleicht ein bisschen Aufklärungsarbeit betreiben können. Das würde ich doch sehr begrüßen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ist das was, also ich stelle mich jetzt, also auch ihr als Club so, man sieht, also da gibt es dieses Konstrukt, ja, Nachrichtendienst, da ist so ein Dienst, der ist total unsicher und die Leute benutzen das trotzdem, schlägt man dann irgendwie die Hände über den Kopf zusammen und sagt, ja, mach doch, es ist uns doch egal oder gibt es da noch so eine Art Bildungsauftrag, das wir uns jetzt vornehmen, ok, 2013, wir predigen mal ein bisschen.
Naja, das ist schon, unser Sendungsbewusstsein geht da schon in die Richtung, aber wahrscheinlich kennst du diesen Effekt auch, wenn man da so nach zwei Monaten das erste Mal in seine Küche kommt, nicht aufgeräumt hatte und dann so, wo sich dann die Gummihandschuhe anziehen muss, um irgendwo anzusetzen.
Okay, warte, ich möchte das kurz zusammenfassen. Leute, wenn ihr weiter WhatsApp benutzt, dann kommt irgendwann Erdgeist mit dem Gummihandschuh. Also wenn das jetzt nicht Argumentation genug ist, dann weiß ich es auch nicht. Aber ernstlich, soll man das noch weiter versuchen oder vertreibt man dann irgendwann auch Leute, wenn man sie von etwas zu bekehren versucht, was ja eigentlich total praktisch aussieht?
Ich bin eigentlich mal großer Verfechter von Dingen vor Leben, von eventuell...
Also ich meine, wir machen ja auch Chaos macht Schule, ist ja auch eine Initiative des Chaos Computer Clubs, wo halt Leute aus dem Chaos Computer Club in Schulen gehen, um dort Aufklärungsarbeit zu machen. Und naja, vor zwei, drei Jahren, da hat man dann immer noch vor Facebook gewarnt. Aber es ist doch jetzt überhaupt nicht mehr zeitgemäß in eine Schule zu gehen. Ich mein, es hat sich bei Facebook gar nichts verändert, es ist ja eher noch schlimmer geworden. Aber man kann einfach dann nicht mehr sagen, steigt bei Facebook aus. Für WhatsApp kriegt man das vielleicht noch hin.
Aber man kann jetzt sagen, benutzt es wenigstens auf so eine bestimmte Art und Weise.
Ich glaube, bei WhatsApp wird es noch schwieriger, weil das eben gerade bei Schülern und jungen Leuten, die wenig Geld haben, einfach mal essentiell wichtiges Kommunikationsmittel geworden ist.
Ja, aber selbst da gibt es doch Alternativen. Das verstehe ich halt. Echt, welche denn? Es gibt wahrscheinlich nichts, wo ihr jetzt sagen würdet, ey, das ist super, das dürft ihr alle benutzen, aber zum Beispiel gibt es KICK zum kleinen Dienst, also A ist da kein Telefonbuch-Upload, B verschlüsselt er seine Nachrichten, also zumindest nicht wirklich von User zu User, aber immerhin die Kommunikation zum Server. Das ist sozusagen nicht das perfekte Ding, aber es ist ein kleiner Schritt besser.
Der eigentliche Weg wäre eigentlich dahin, zu lobbyen, einfach SMSen kostenlos zu machen.
Warum schreibt ihr so was nicht? Warum schreibt ihr so was nicht?
Zeit, Zeit.
Ich sag das immer wieder, das habe ich vorhin auch schon gesagt, dass es einfach ein unding ist, dass für die SMS immer noch derart viel kassiert wird.
Okay, das heißt also Forderung wäre dann quasi so, liebe Telekommunikationsanbieter, ihr schlagt jetzt einfach nochmal, keine Ahnung, 2, 99 Euro für den Tarif drauf und dafür das SMS ab.
Ach, die kosten doch in Wirklichkeit nix. Was denn das mal für eine...
Kostet wirklich nix? Ich habe ja neulich gelernt, hier auch in einem Chaosradio, wo wir mal über das Internet gesprochen haben, dass Daten schon auch Kosten verursachen.
Na ja, es gibt da Interconnect-Kosten für so Gespräche und es haben auch Telefoniefirmen angefangen damit Geld zu verdienen, dass ihre User angerufen worden sind. Diese Interconnect-Kosten sind ja jetzt auch von der Regulierungsbehörde begrenzt worden. Auf was war sie? Unter zwei Cent. Aber da gibt es noch mal eine eigene Chaosradio-Sendung nächstes Jahr.
Schreib dich das mal auf, was sie hier schon ein Thema so angesagt haben. Das müsst ihr noch einfordern.
Eine Alternative, Entschuldige, ich würde nur sagen, dass SMSen dort einfach im Mikrosent-Bereich nicht wirklich was ausmachen. Und wenn alle Anbieter in Deutschland einfach sagen würden, ja, pff, dann eben nicht. Aber es gibt halt noch Leute, die...
Selbst dann würden die Leute glaube ich aber tatsächlich WhatsApp nutzen, weil das kann ja auch Video, das kann ja auch Töne, das kann Gruppenunterhaltung und so weiter und so fort. Also SMS sozusagen.
Aber da hast du dann den Preis ungefähr schon was die Leute bereit sind dafür auszugeben. Also wenn ihnen bewusst ist, dass WhatsApp irgendwann mal Geld kostet, dann hast du ja schon ungefähr das Gefühl dafür, was so Leute noch dafür bereit sind auszugeben für einen convenient Chat-Tool mit Bildertransferieren.
Nee, wartet mal. Ich muss mal kurz hier... Das geht heute alles drunter und drüber. Ich schieb das alles auf euch. Immer noch das Chaos Radio im Blue Moon und wir haben jetzt tatsächlich eine Anruferin zu WhatsApp. Hallo und guten Tag Tanja. So, erste Frage, nutzt du WhatsApp?
Warum? Weil es mir Spaß macht und ich hab mich tierisch geärgert, als ich eben euch zugehört hab und dachte, was für ein klugscheißer Männerverein. Aber dann hörte ich, ah ja, okay, Chaos Computer Club, die kennen sich natürlich aus. Und wie ihr Jungs euch denn damit beschäftigt habt, ihr beschäftigt euch wahrscheinlich mit wenig anderem. Und Leute, die vielleicht einfach Dinge mal benutzen, weil sie Spaß dran haben und vielleicht nicht immer sofort über die Sicherheitsfrage nachgedacht haben, werden hier verurteilt und jeder gewacht. Also das find ich echt ein bisschen frech.
Na ja, aber tatsächlich ist es ja bei WhatsApp so, dass nicht sozusagen nur die Auskennung das Wissen, sondern das war heute wieder in den Schlagzeiten.
Ja, dann hab ich heute die Schlagzeiten nicht gesehen. Also ich mein, auf der anderen Seite bin ich ja dankbar, dass ich informiert werde, dass mein komplettes Adressbuch da hochgeladen wird. Das find ich natürlich nicht so sexy, klar. Aber dann würd ich auch sagen, verdammte Scheiße, muss der Chaos Computer Club einfach irgendwie mehr in die Medien, also viel mehr in die Medien.
Aber das find ich jetzt eine spannende Frage. Die ist tatsächlich nicht bewusst gewesen, dass WhatsApp diese Sachen hochlädt?
Ich find es total geil, was sie für Bildchen anbieten. Vielleicht bin ich auch ein Mädchen und find es schön andere Arten von, wie soll ich sagen, Messages zu verschicken. Vielleicht ist euch Jungs das egal, kann ja sein. Also ist jetzt sehr klischeehaft. Ich find es schon schön mit den Bildchen und so. Macht tierisch viel Spaß. Hab mich auch gefreut, als es wieder noch mehr Bildchen gab.
Also du meinst die Smiley's damit?
Ja, natürlich.
Ach so.
Nein, nicht nur Smiley's, das sind ja ein paar mehr Bildchen.
Du, ich find diese Form der Kommunikation auch cool, weil man halt, wo man gerade ist, wo man steht und geht, kann man halt einfach irgendwelche Nachrichten oder irgendwelche Fotos mal rumschicken zu irgendwelchen Leuten. Ja, das ist halt super.
Also von der Anhörung her super geil. Aber klar finde ich, also wenn es so unsicher ist, finde ich es natürlich super scheiße.
Ich glaube, das Hauptproblem ist doch, dass man nicht im Vorfeld darüber aufgeklärt wird, dass man da so einen massiven Verlust an Privatsphäre eingeht. Und aus genau diesem Grund habe ich zum Beispiel auch irgendwann mal gesagt, also als ich das halt auch mal realisiert habe, was das eigentlich ist, habe ich mir eine Alternative gesucht und habe halt überlegt, okay, WhatsApp basiert halt auf einem bestimmten Protokoll, was auch bekannt ist als XMPP oder andere sagen halt Jabba dazu. Das ist halt ein Instant-Messenger, wie man ihn halt vom Computer kennt. Und ich dachte mir, naja, dann gibt es halt bestimmt auch irgendwelche XMPP-Clients fürs Telefon, die dann halt auch über Push-Dienste im Grunde genommen genau das gleiche tun wie WhatsApp. Und ich habe mich halt dann irgendwann tierisch gefreut, dass ich irgendwann einen Instant-Message Client gefunden habe, der auch irgendwie Push macht und die diversen Protokolle unterstützt und so weiter. Und dann habe ich mir das Ding sogar gekauft. Ich habe 10 Euro dafür hingelegt, weil ich dachte, ich habe endlich mal eine Alternative und ich kann da sogar verschlüsselte Nachrichten mit verschicken, weil das Ding OTR unterstützt und so weiter. Und ich habe 10 Euro hingelegt und irgendwann habe ich dann realisiert, Moment, wo quatscht dieses Ding eigentlich überall hin? Und dann habe ich mal geguckt, ich habe halt einfach nur gesehen, dass da halt unglaublich viele verschiedene Systeme im Internet angesprochen wurden. Und das liegt daran, dass das Ding, diese Applikation, von der ich jetzt annahm, sie würde mir mal meinen Hintern retten, dass die alle meine Kommunikation auch über die eigenen Server geleitet haben. Ja genau, und dafür habe ich gerade 10 Euro hingelegt und zwei Stunden später habe ich realisiert, das ist ja noch beschissener. Das ist zum Kotzen, das ist so frustrierend, das glaubst du gar nicht.
Lasst uns wieder.
Darf ich dich noch ein bisschen darüber freuen, oder?
Dass uns auch so ein kluges Teufel passiert, ist in Ordnung, oder?
Was glaubst du, wir sind da keine, also ich meine, wir sehen doch auch, was da passiert.
Entschuldigung, Leute, ganz ruhig, immer nur einer auf einmal.
Ach komm, unterschätzt mal deine Hörer nicht.
Nein, es geht mir, es ist mein persönliches Anliegen, ich kann euch einfach nicht alle gleichzeitig zuhören, deswegen so. Außerdem müssen wir ja gleich auch wieder weiter. Tanja, dir auf jeden Fall vielen Dank. Ja, gerne. Also A, hoffe ich, dass ein bisschen Aufklärung auch an dieser Stelle stattgefunden hat. Ich würde dir tatsächlich mal empfehlen, wenn es nicht zu kompliziert ist, heise.de zu klicken. Da gab es heute einen langen Artikel über...
Das ist gar nicht kompliziert.
über die WhatsApp schon wieder eine Lücke hatte. Kann man dann da mal nachlesen. Und viel Spaß und vielleicht gibt es ja doch mal einen anderen Service. So, jetzt machen wir schnell noch den Robert. Hallo, Robert. Müssen wir uns aber beeilen, weil wir dann sozusagen über die Jahresrepublik, weiteres Thema etc. Du wolltest mal kurz zu WhatsApp sagen, warum es den Leuten egal ist, was da passiert.
Ja, bei erstens wird man ja, wenn man das runterlädt, nun neuerdings wirklich aufgeklärt darüber, wo das alles zugreift. Und ich meine, in einer Welt, wo Facebook die Welt wirklich regiert und Facebook alles weiß und dort Bilder hochgeladen werden, die eigentlich, wo man weiß, dass Facebook die Verwerbung und so einen Scheißtrick nutzen kann, dann ist es glaube ich auch egal, ob WhatsApp irgendwelche Kontaktdaten oder sowas hochladen kann. Weil, ja, das ist jedenfalls meine Meinung. Und deswegen denke ich auch, dass viele sagen, wisst ihr was, Facebook, die kennen jetzt schon mein ganzes Leben, dann kann das WhatsApp auch können, weil nutzen tut es sowieso keiner richtig. Also dass er jetzt sagt, hier, ey Mensch, du hast da eine geile Nachricht, die benutze ich in Werbeslogan oder wie auch immer. Oder ich ziehe jetzt einfach mal den Namen raus.
Das wäre sozusagen deine einzige Sorge, dass Inhalte von dir für irgendwas verwendet werden?
Das ist nicht mal eine Sorge, weil dadurch steht ja in den AGBs da drin, bei Facebook, dass sie das machen dürfen. Und dadurch, sobald man sich da anmeldet, stimmt man dadurch zu.
Und du sagst, und dir ist es egal?
Ja, weil ich bin da ehrlich gesagt, stelle ich da selten was rein, was da nicht reingehört, beziehungsweise gar nicht, also ich achte schon drauf.
Okay, aber lass mal bitte Facebook außen vor lassen, weil das ist ja ein Ding, das kann man so benutzen. WhatsApp ist ja sozusagen ein SMS-Stellvertreter, das heißt, da schreiben die Leute auch sehr persönlich. Wie ist es da?
Ja, da ist es natürlich ein bisschen, man sollte da schon aufpassen, dass man jetzt nicht irgendwelchen Mist verbreitet oder irgendwas. Mir geht es auch gerade ziemlich auf den Sack mit den ganzen Ketten-Mails, die dort geschrieben werden, dass es kostenspflichtig wird und sowas. Aber ehrlich gesagt, nehme ich sowas in Kauf, weil irgendwann kommt sowieso alles raus und dass wir überwacht werden. So ist jedenfalls meine Meinung, ich weiß ja nicht, wie andere dazu stehen.
Na gut, Robert, dann kann man sagen, das ist jetzt entscheidend, warum man nicht mehr viel machen kann, aber dann wünsche ich dir viel Glück und hoffe, dass du nicht recht hast.
Ja, das hoffe ich ehrlich gesagt auch, aber das wird sich nicht vermeiden lassen.
Na dann, viel Spaß.
Markus, du weißt aber auch, dass dein Name und deine Telefonnummer, mein Name und meine Telefonnummer auch auf den WhatsApp-Server liegen.
Ja, das ist ja das, was mich so ankotzt. Verstehst du, die Leute sollen doch bitte ihre eigene Telefonnummer hochladen, wenn sie wollen. Was mich ankotzt ist sozusagen, dass auch die ganzen Daten von anderen Leuten drin sind.
Dann ruf doch mal bei WhatsApp an und sag, die sollen das da bitte löschen.
Datenschutzauskunft gleich.
Klar, WhatsApp, die sitzen wo? Kanada, Amerika, USA?
Internet.
Kalman.
Zum Landgericht Hamburg hingehen und sagen.
Apropos Gericht, ich möchte sagen, eine scharfe Kurve ziehen und Frank Rieger ans Telefon holen. Hallo und guten Abend, Frank Rieger.
Guten Abend, du bist aber scharf abgebungen.
Ja, in der Tat. Das muss aber auch mal sein, weil die Leute hier, wenn du nicht mit im Studio bist, dann benehmen die sich hier wie die Letzten. Egal, genau. Es ist ja nicht so, dass du nicht die Chance hast. Egal. Frank, du bist auch vom Chaos Computer Club. Das wissen vielleicht nicht alle. Jetzt wird hier gerade eine Bierflasche geöffnet. Ich fass es nicht. Und du warst wegen des Antiterrorgesetzes. Vorm?
Das Antiterrordateigesetz.
Das Antiterrordateigesetz vom Bundesverfassungsgericht. Leute, stoß doch wenigstens leise an. So, vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht?
Beim Bundesverfassungsgericht. Unsere Stellungnahme hat Konstanze abgegeben.
Worum ging es da genau?
Es geht darum, dass jemand gegen die Antiterrordatei geklagt hat. Die Antiterrordatei ist eine Datei, die zwischen den Polizeibehörden und den Geheimdiensten ein Informationsaustausch ermöglicht, der über das Trennungsgebot zwischen Polizei und Geheimdiensten hinausgeht. In Deutschland ist es ja so, dass nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg eine Trennung von Polizei und Geheimdiensten instanziert wurde, weil man gesagt hat, man will wieder sowas wie eine geheime Staatspolizei haben, die sowohl polizeiliche Befugnisse hat, also jemand festnehmen oder in den Knast schmeißen kann, als auch irgendwie geheimdienstliche Mittel verfügt. Das wird doch von den allermeisten Leuten eigentlich so als ein wesentlicher Grundsatz des Sicherheitskonzepts in einer BRD angesehen. Und diese Datei unterminiert das und führt das halt aus. Und eines der Probleme dabei ist, die wird halt zwischen so über 60 Behörden geteilt, diese Datei. Und da können auch zum Beispiel Leute drinstehen, die gar nichts davon wissen, also die überhaupt nicht mit Terrorismus irgendwie zu tun haben, nur weil sie jemanden kennen, der viel zufällig möglicherweise in den Verdacht gerät, Terrorist zu sein. Und die haben eigentlich auch nie wirklich eine Chance, sich dagegen zu wehren, weil wenn man möchte, dass man diese Datei gelöscht wird, falls man es dann doch mal irgendwie erfahren hat, dann muss man irgendwie alle diese Behörden abklappern, um herauszukriegen, welche von diesen Behörden die da Daten da eigentlich reingestellt hat. Und dagegen wurde halt von der Verfassung durchgeklagt. Und da haben wir auch eine Stellungnahme abgegeben, die jetzt noch schriftlich veröffentlicht wurde, um mal darzulegen, was da das Problem mit dieser Datei ist.
Es ist ja so, du hast es gerade erläutert, also Trennung, Geheimdienst, Polizei, ganz klare Sache. Wieso gibt es denn auch eine Gerichtsverhandlung? Also was ist denn die Gegenargumentation? Beziehungsweise was steht denn da jetzt noch im Weg, dass das wieder verboten wird?
Na die Gegenargumentation ist natürlich halt wegen der Sicherheit. Also wir müssen ja was gegen die bösen Terroristen tun. Und dementsprechend müssen sich halt Polizisten und Geheimdienste austauschen, das ist halt das Argument. Und da ist natürlich ein Stück weit was dran. Es ist halt schon klar, dass dagegen natürlich auch Erkenntnisse auf der einen oder anderen Seite der Barrikade anfallen, die dann halt ermittelt werden sollten. Eigentlich ist die Art und Weise, wie das da passiert, halt sehr, wie sagt man, freihändig. Auch internationale Daten aus dieser Datei können durch auch internationalen Geheimdiensten oder Polizeibehörden geteilt werden. Und eines der Dinge, die wir halt da im Kern bemängelt haben, war auch, dass da immer so getan wurde, als würde es sich um eine Datei handeln, wo ein einzelner Beamter davor sitzt und dann mal einen Namen eingibt und dann irgendwie mal ein Aktenzeichen daraus bekommt, was dann bei einer anderen Behörde möglicherweise zu den Daten führt, die er sucht. In der Realität ist aber so, dass halt so ein polizeilicher Fahndungssoftware, die halt auch automatische Anfragen generieren kann und Daten in einer anderen Beziehung setzen kann und die eigentlich aus dem geheimdienstlichen Bereich kommt und auch bei den Geheimdiensten auch noch verwendet wird. In jedem Fall ist es auch für RS Case, dass die Schildstellerin diese Antiterror-Datei hat und das auch in den Prospekten der Hersteller angepriesen wird, dass sie genau diese Funktionalität hat. Dass man halt einfach diese Darstellung, dass der Beamte da nur mal gelegentlich ein Aktenzeichen heraus sucht, was er heute völlig falsch vor Gericht dargestellt hat. Die Verhandlung selber war nicht so interessant wie die sonstigen Verhandlungen von fastes Gericht. Aber mal gucken, das Urteil wird dann irgendwann nächstes Jahr kommen.
Hast du schon eine Tendenz, was du glaubst, was rauskommt?
Ich vermute mal aus der Verhandlung raus, dass sie die Antiterror-Datei einschränken werden. Dass sie sagen, okay, dieses und jenes geht nicht, diese Details müsste wieder löschen, diese Art und Weise des Vorgehens müsste löschen. Was auch unter anderem damit zu tun hat, dass die Behörden vor Gericht versucht haben, den Eindruck zu erwecken, dass sie sowieso den Rahmen des Gesetzes nicht ausschöpfen, sondern viel weniger tun, als sie eigentlich nach dem Gesetz dürften. Und in solchen Fällen hat das Verfassungsgerät eigentlich schon immer dazu tendiert zu sagen, dann schränken wir das Gesetz halt mal soweit ein auf das, was wir tatsächlich nachweislich eurer Arbeit brauchen, nicht der Ruhigenamt.
Was jetzt gerade interessant war, ist, du hast ja das Wort Hersteller in diesem Zusammenhang für die Software. Ich finde ja auch nochmal, das Thema ein bisschen aufzumachen, das 2012 das Jahr war, wo in der Öffentlichkeit eine viel größere Rolle gespielt hat, dass es für diese ganzen Sachen Hersteller gibt. Also Waffentechnologie, Spionage, Software, Fahndungsdatenbanken, glaubst du, das sozusagen gerückt jetzt immer mehr ins Licht der Öffentlichkeit?
Ja, das ist natürlich dadurch ins Licht der Öffentlichkeit gerückt, aber das ist halt besonders, dass in allen nordafrikanischen Ländern Akten gefunden wurden, auch von westlichen Herstellern, die da Spionage-Software und Drucksoftware geliefert haben. Und die Frage, was mit dieser Technologie ist, wieso es die überhaupt gibt und ob die nicht exportkontrolliert ist und welchen Regeln in der Nutzung dieser Technologie unterliegen sollte, dass die dadurch viel mehr in den Fokus gelangt ist. Und wir haben sich hier einen Teil dazu beigetragen, also auch der Kongress steht da dieses Jahr unter dem Motto Not My Department, was durchaus auch eine Anspielung und ein Hinweis darauf ist, zu sagen, okay, wer von Leuten aus den Eckers von der Arbeit eigentlich in solchen Firmen ist, das ist in Ordnung, was hat man da für eine moralische Beurteilung zu treffen und gibt es da nicht Alternativen dazu.
Kannst du schon in die Kristallkugel gucken und sagen, was da nächstes Jahr Thema sein wird in diesem Bereich?
Nicht wirklich, nein. Viel ist natürlich von News-Events getrieben, also wenn halt wieder Sachen aufgedeckt werden, wenn solche Software doch mal in der Öffentlichkeit analysiert wird. Klar ist jedenfalls, dass so die beiden großen Bereiche, Trojaner und die Packet-Inspection, durchaus wichtig bleiben werden, weil da doch eine Menge passiert und ich vermute mal möglicherweise auch Forensik-Software und halt so Fahndungs- und Geheimdienst-Software, die halt in dieser Datenvermaschung und Vernetzung ermöglichen, dass die noch nächstes Jahr durchaus wichtiger werden.
Na, der Bundesnachrichtendienst sucht ja immer noch, nein, der BKA sucht immer noch Leute, die ihn da in Bundesteuern anaprogrammieren. Auch jetzt bei öffentlicher Ausschreibung. Hat sich wohl bisher jemand gefunden, der darauf Lust hat?
Ja, das wäre eigentlich ein ganz gutes Zeichen, dass offensichtlich doch irgendwie Großvorteile der qualifizierten Menschen halt keine Lust haben, sich an solchen Entwicklungen zu beteiligen.
Nun gut, und wir werden dann möglicherweise nächstes Jahr dann auch wieder von dir erfahren, wo es da eine Gerichtsverhandlung gab. Frank, vielen Dank und viel Spaß noch. So, die großen Sachen, die heute hier im Minutentakt durchs Netz fliegen.
Du hast aber noch nicht erklärt, warum es Not My Department heißt.
Da wollte ich ja sozusagen warten bis sozusagen die Nachhalb 12, weil wir dann jetzt sagen, das große Kongress-Teasing aufmachen. Aber wie gesagt, machen wir später. Wir haben ja noch eine sehr, sehr, sehr lange Liste. Was haben wir denn jetzt noch hier? Der böse Wolf? Wieso steht denn der böse Wolf auf? Wer hat den bösen Wolf auf die Liste geschrieben?
Der kommt doch später.
Der kommt auch später? Was kommt denn dann jetzt?
Du bist doch normalerweise so aufgeräumt hier in diesen Sendungen.
EU-Datenschutzverordnung. Man bereitet die Sendung vor, alles sieht nach einer großen, großartigen Liste aus. Da können wir echt lange viel zu erzählen. Und dann steht ja sowas wie EU-Datenschutzverordnung sowie Richtlinie.
Herrlich.
Ja, weiß wieder keiner. Na gut. Schlangenkuchen. Das ist nochmal zurück zum Höhepaarrecht. Schlangenkuchen ist jetzt gerade die letzte große Abmahn-Geschichte. Es wird ja immer wieder, also jedes Jahr eigentlich geht es darum, dass irgendein Blogger abgemahnt wird, weil er irgendein Bild hingestellt hat, wo er keine Urheberrechte oder Verwertungsrechte dran hat. Und dann kommt irgendein Anwalt und sagt so nein, das darfst du nicht, hier zahl mir 1000 Euro. Und es gibt jetzt sozusagen, also in den letzten Monaten hat eine Firma von sich Reden gemacht, die immer mal wieder abmahnt. Die war dann auch mal im Gerede, weil sie angeblich von dem einen Foto gar nicht so wirklich die Nutzungsrechte hatte. Und dann jetzt taucht der Verdacht auf. Also man möge mich bitte sozusagen nicht festhalten. Also es taucht der Verdacht. Also es gibt Leute, die vermuten, es könnte so sein, dass die Firma Folgendes macht. Sie guckt im Netz, welche Bilder total viral verbreitet werden. Also zum Beispiel das von einer Schlange, die total echt aussieht, die in Wirklichkeit aber ein Kuchen ist. Und wenn dieses Bild richtig weit rumgegangen ist, dann geht sie zu der Frau oder dem Typen, der das Foto gemacht hat und sagt, du willst uns nicht vielleicht mal die Verwertungsrechte an dem Bild verkaufen. Und dann geht es hin und dann ist das Bild ja schon überall im Netz und mahnt all die Leute, die es im Netz verbreitet haben, ab. Guter Plan, oder? Sollte man das Thema unterbinden?
Also, naja, sich so ein Bild zu nehmen und irgendwo weiter zu verbreiten, wo die Urheberrechte nicht klar sind, ist halt immer mit einem gewissen Risiko verbunden. Da muss man... Ja, ist halt natürlich... Meine Sympathien für die Leute, die da zum Abmahnen rumgehen, sind da auch sehr, sehr im engen Rahmen. Aber wenn man so ein Bild nimmt, das viral verbreitet, dann muss man sich da immer mit... auseinandersetzen, wo es herkommt. Irgendwie muss man da ja, wie gesagt, wie ich vorhin andeutete, abwägen zwischen...
Es gibt halt sozusagen einen nicht geringen Anteil, vielleicht ist es auch ein geringer Anteil, aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein lauter Anteil der deutschen Blogger, die sagen so, das geht so nicht weiter, weil so funktioniert das Netz. Das Netz funktioniert genauso, dass alles viral verbreitet wird. Das muss irgendwie gehen, das muss mal geändert werden.
Das Problem ist eigentlich eher, dass auf der anderen Seite das mit der Abmahnung da angegangen werden muss. Dass dieses Unwesen, also das ist eigentlich in Deutschland ziemlich eigen. Ich hab da mal, wo war denn das? Ach, in der Kimbell-Geschichte wurde ich ja befragt von der neuseeländischen Presse und dann hab ich den versucht zu erklären, dass Kimbell damals die Abmahnanwälte da mit dem Grafenreus zusammen eigentlich aus dem Boden gestampft hat. Und die kamen da mit diesem Konzept überhaupt nicht klar, dass so eine kostenpflichtige Abmahnung, wo dann die Gegenseite auch gleich noch Anwaltskosten und alles damit bezahlen muss, und wie dieses Konzept ist in Deutschland, ich weiß nicht, ob es weltweit einmalig ist, aber es ist sonst im Ausland ziemlich unbekannt. Und da muss man da glaube ich mal ran, dass das so für, naja, eigentlich Bagatellen irgendwie gleich Abmahnkosten in irgendeiner Größe aufzurufen, die da eine Industrie draus entstehen lassen, das ist da eigentlich das, woran es krankt. Das würde alles nicht passieren, wenn man da nicht beliebig Geld generieren könnte. Und ich glaube, das ist dann eher die Lösung, als auf der anderen Seite gleich zu sagen, man muss als irgendjemand, der ein Werk ins Netz gestellt hat, komplett alle seine Rechte daran aufgeben, bloß weil es sich gerade viral verbreitet.
Das ist ja auch der interessante Punkt, den man dieses Jahr auch lernen konnte, nicht die Leute, die sich mit Computer-Internet beschäftigen, sind automatisch dafür, dass es gar kein Urheberrecht mehr gibt. Wollt ihr noch mal über die Kulturwertmark reden eigentlich, fällt mir auf?
Naja, also ich denke, das ist nach wie vor ein wichtiges Konzept, vor allen Dingen. Und das ist das, was viele Leute nicht verstehen. Die Kulturwertmark ist ja auch sowas, was eben die Privatkopie auch langfristig sichern kann. Weil, naja, irgendwie muss es eine Vergütung geben. Und ich meine, das kann ja neben der Kulturwertmark...
Maha, von vorne. Kulturwertmark ist...
Na ja, es hängt damit zusammen, dass es eine Abgabe gibt auf den Internetanschluss. Und das soll aber jetzt nicht über irgendwelche Verteilungsgesellschaften verteilt werden, wie das jetzt schon der Fall ist. Es ist zwar nicht auf den Internetanschluss, aber auf Speichermedien gibt es bereits Abgaben. Da zahlen wir alle. Und dann gibt es halt Organisationen. Es gibt die sogenannte ZBY, die Zentralstelle für... Ach, ich weiß es gar nicht. Also jedenfalls, die sitzen bei der GEMA. Und die verteilen dann das eingenommene Geld. Und die Idee vom Chaos Computer Club ist, dass das sozusagen die Nutzer selber machen können. Dass sie halt selber eben solche Kultur, einen Kulturwertmarkt verteilen an Sachen, an Urheber, die sie gut finden und so. Dass das also dezentral ist und damit eben sehr datensparsam. Und das ist halt dann ein großer Vorteil. Und dadurch, dass es so etwas gibt, ist halt die Privatkopie sichergestellt. Denn das ist ja, dass in Deutschland gibt es halt die Möglichkeit der Privatkopie, weil es eben auch eine Abgabe dafür gibt. Und ohne die Abgabe wird auch die Privatkopie gefährdet sein. Die müssen wir natürlich auf jeden Fall sichern.
Jetzt ist ja die Kulturwertmarkt aber sozusagen ein Konzept, das ist relativ kompliziert zu erklären. Der Name ist sperrig, war die Kritik und, und, und, und. Es ist auch vom Club ja als Diskussionsgrundlage angekündigt worden. Also nicht als, ich müsste es jetzt genau so machen, sondern nur so, wir wollen nicht nur immer meckern, sondern wir wollen auch mal einen positiven Vorschlag machen. Gibt es denn jetzt eigentlich eine Diskussion? Also hat da noch mal irgendwie Weiterentwicklung stattgefunden oder steht das jetzt einfach nur so im Raum und man kann immer nur wieder hinzeigen und sagen, ja wir haben doch aber mal was gemacht?
Das kann man natürlich sowieso immer, aber wir hatten auch, na so was trägt halt meistens länger. Sowas muss man da in den wissenschaftlichen Diskurs einbringen, denn beschäftigen sich dort da Philosophen und Soziologen und Juristen da mit und die haben da immer so eine Vorwärmphase und da muss man dann, naja, denen muss man da erstmal so Gedankenputter hinwerfen und die übereilen auch nichts. Und mit denen hatten wir da so, eigentlich in auch so mäßiger Frequenz, aber hatten da auch gute Gespräche gehabt. Wohl gute Gespräche haben wir sich auch. Und generell wird dieses Konzept auch begrüßt und verstanden, weil es so die Entscheidung dort wieder aus den Gremien zurücknimmt und demokratisiert. Und wenn das allgegenwärtig ist, dass man auch ständig connected ist und ständig diese Kulturwertmarken vergeben kann, weiß nicht so Leute, die Flatter benutzen, so ein System, mit dem man im Internet Kleinstmengen spenden kann, an Dinge an Blogposts, an Tweets, an Software, die einem gefallen. Dieses Konzept funktioniert so leidlich. Man kann nicht davon leben, außer einige Ausnahmen, aber es kommt da schon so ein bisschen was bei rum und man fühlt sich natürlich immer geschmeichelt. Und das ist so eine auch institutionalisierte Art und Weise, jemanden anderen zu schmeicheln. Das ist schon so ein Zeichen, dass es ein Weg ist, der funktioniert. Und wenn man das dann am Ende dann auch noch juristisch irgendwie festklopft, dann glaube ich schon, dass da was draus werden kann. Für konkrete Hoffnung müsste man da selber, glaube ich, nochmal mit sich in den Arsch treten.
Doch, ich glaube, es besteht Hoffnung. Ich war ja selber auf einem Podium dabei in München beim Ministerium. Und da war eben auch einer von der ZBÜ im Publikum, der dann nachher zu mir gesagt hat, das würde ihm sofort einleuchten. Also das sei für ihn kein Problem. Während die rechte Vertreter, ich saß da mit lauter Lobbyisten, gut ich bin natürlich auch einer für den CCC, aber ich saß da mit lauter anderen Lobbyisten auf dem Podium, die haben gleich geschrien, ah nee, Kulturwerdenmarkt, wir wollen doch unsere Inhalte verkaufen, wir wollen nicht irgendwie, also die Privatkopie, nee, wir wollen halt mehr verkaufen. Und ich denke, da gibt es schon nochmal eine ganz interessante andere Front. Dass also plötzlich die Leute von der ZBÜ sagen, ja können wir was überlegen, und dann aber wieder die Urheber kommen und sagen, nicht die Urheber, das haben sie selber schon in die Falle getan. Also die rechte Verwerter, die sogenannten Leistungsschutzverträger, da sieht auch keiner mehr durch. die dann sagen, wir wollen ja irgendwie auch noch was verdienen. Also da gibt es dann schon nochmal ganz neue Koalitionen. Also von daher sehe ich das nicht ganz so pessimistisch.
Okay, also da kann noch was draus werden, aber es wird jetzt nicht wie die CD3S gleich im Januar losgehen. Apropos im Internet Dinge verkaufen, was ist eigentlich mit Bitcoins? Bitcoins waren, da hatten wir also schon länger her mal eine Sendung im Chaosradio drüber gemacht, eine, ich will jetzt nicht sagen virtuelle Währung, eine elektronische Währung. Also an Geld, das nur durch Umtauschkurs in Geld wie wir es kennen sozusagen einen Wert erhält und das sozusagen durch Rechenkraft berechnet wird. Das wurde sehr groß so 2011 und dann gab es so ein paar größere Skandale, wo halt irgendwie größere Mengen dieses Geldes des Bitcoins weggekommen sind. Und ich habe aber jetzt, soll ich mal sehen, das gibt es immer noch, oder? Gibt es einen Status?
Das gibt es immer noch. Unter dem Bekanntenkreis gibt es auch Leute, die da noch weiter Minor betreiben. Also diese Zahlen ausrechnen und dann Strom in Bitcoins verwandeln. Und es gibt auch Bürgerberatereien, mit denen man da bezahlen kann.
Naja, keine.
Also so der richtige große Durchbruch ist da bei Bitcoin noch nicht rausgekommen. Aber zu richtigen Neuigkeiten, außer so die negativen News, dass die Wallets weggekommen sind, habe ich auch nicht gehört.
Gibt es denn überhaupt irgendwas zu bezahlen im Netz? Neues, also so, dass man so Kleinstbeträge irgendwie mal weggeben kann oder sowas?
Die einzig spannende Geschichte, die ich jetzt so gesehen habe, ist, dass es total Mainstream wird, anonyme Kreditkarten sicher zu organisieren. Du kannst jetzt an die Tanke gehen, kannst dort Geld dalassen und bekommst eine Prepaid-Kreditkarte, auf die du Geld auch anonym einzahlen kannst. Das Einzige, was sie da sehen wollen, ist eine Mobiltelefonnummer, an die man eine SMS geschickt bekommt. Aber da es ja dabei Aldi Talk auch anonyme Prepaid-Mobilfunkkarten gibt, kann man sich da jetzt wirklich anonyme fürs Internet bezahlen, taugliche Visa-Karten klicken.
Die kann man tatsächlich sozusagen mit... Also gibt's wahrscheinlich auch von anderen Anbietern der Vollständigkeit halber?
Nee, das ist ja nicht von Visa. Ich glaube, dasselbe gibt's da wie auch im Mastercard von derselben Firma. Aber ich...
Es wird Zeit, dass das Jahr zu Ende geht, oder?
Welches Jahr?
So, also mit dem anonymen Betahlen, das wird erstmal Plastigeld. Was ist eigentlich, apropos Plastikarten, nächster Gedankensprung, was ist mit der kranken Dingens... Na hier, sag schon. Elektronische Gesundheitskarten. Elektronische Gesundheitskarten. Mir hat auch nicht meine Krankenkasse angerufen, hat gesagt so, Herr Richter, wir hatten Ihnen noch eine Mail geschrieben, dass Sie uns ein Foto schicken wollen. Ich habe keine Post bekommen. Gibt es irgendwie Neuigkeiten? Also Plan war ja so eine Chipkarte einzuführen, wo irgendwie die komplette Krankenakte drauf geht. Gibt es noch? Weiß das einer?
Naja, die Akte sollte ja nicht drauf sein, aber man sollte mit der Chipkarte Zugang zum Krankenakte haben. Das ist alles ein bisschen, hat sich alles ein bisschen verzögert. Offenbar ist das so eine Art, weiß ich nicht, Autobahn-Maut-Geschichte, die nicht so richtig in Gang kommt. Aber ich kenne den aktuellen Status nicht. Aber ich bin eigentlich ganz froh, wenn es nicht so schnell geht damit, weil das doch ein ziemliches Problem darstellt.
Ist das denn so, ist dann so Verschleppung sowas auch, wo man sagt, okay, naja, da haben sich am Anfang so Leute drüber gewehrt, lass uns mal einfach lange damit brauchen, das einzuführen, dann fällt es nicht so auf. Ist das politisch?
Ne, das glaube ich nicht. Also ich glaube wirklich, dass da viele, viele Firmen viel versprochen haben, was man nicht so schnell halten kann. So ähnlich wie bei den Zügen für die Deutsche Bahn.
Oder den Berliner Flughafen voll.
Oder die E-Mail.
Genau. Die E-Mail passt noch besser eigentlich.
Was ist denn damit eigentlich, die E-Mail? Da gab es noch den anderen Anbieter.
Keine Ahnung.
Also nur zur Erklärung, es gibt den Plan sozusagen, von der Post glaube ich und von der Telekom aus, dass man E-Mails schicken kann, die dann sicher unterschrieben sind, die dann pro, genau, der E-Postbrief, die dann pro Mail Geld kosten. Und auch sozusagen von der Verschlüsselung so her, dass sie nicht wirklich verschlüsselt sind, sondern man verschlüsselt sie, bis man sie zur Post gibt. Die darf das aufmachen und dann wird es nochmal verschlüsselt. Also totaler Quatsch gibt das mittlerweile oder ist das eingestampft worden?
Die machen da nur ganz groß Werbung. Ich war ja da erstaunt. Ich bin neulich an irgendeinen Browser geraten, ohne Adblock und da war gleich oben Prankte groß, ich glaube irgendein Fußballverein aus Bayern, hat da irgendwie auch gleich noch einen Werbevertrag mit denen. Ich weiß nicht mehr wie der hieß, Bayern München oder so. Und da wird gerade große Mengen Geld reingepumpt, wie es aussieht. Und ich hab da im Netz selber wenig von gehört.
Also falls, wir machen es einfach so, falls einer von euch einen E-Postbrief oder eine DND-E-Mail tatsächlich schon mal benutzt hat, kann er gerne anrufen. 0331 70 97 110. Und wir machen solange das Fritz Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Zum letzten Mal in diesem Jahr das Chaos Radio mit drei Gestalten aus dem Chaos Computer Club, nämlich Maha, THS und Erdgeist. Und wir werden gleich nochmal über den Kongress reden, der dieses Jahr auch wieder stattfindet. Die Frage, die ich vorhin noch habe, ist, die hier steht noch in dem Stichpunktzettel, Drohnen sind nun Alltag.
Also in den Vereinigten Staaten ist ja wohl grad gang und gäbe, dass der Krieg im Ausland nicht mehr mit Soldaten auf dem Boden geführt wird, sondern dass dort die Drohnen hin und her fliegen und Terror verbreiten, um dort die militärischen Ziele durchzusetzen. Und es scheint dort außer in einigen informierten Kreisen einfach total gang und gäbe zu sein, dass Drohnen jetzt so das Kriegsmittel der Wahl sind. Und wahrscheinlich wird sich das nur ändern, bis wenn dann Drohnen so billig geworden sind, dass jeder auch über dem Boden der Vereinigten Staaten selber eine hat und dann das da so ein bisschen zurückschwappt.
Also irgendwann wird alle jemand eine haben und dann gibt es keine Soldaten mehr?
Dann gibt es keine Ruhe mehr, glaube ich. Weil die Berichte, die ich da gesehen habe, die Dokumentationen von den Landstrichen, die dort von Drohnen regelmäßig kontrolliert werden, sind schon echt angsterregend. Wenn du einfach ständig über dir irgendwie das fliegende Auge schweben hast, wo du nicht weißt, ob es guckt oder schießt, dann zermürbt dich das einfach. Da zermürbt es auch die Grundpfeiler der Gesellschaft. Und ich denke, das ist so eins der großen Themen für die nächsten fünf Jahre, wo wir uns dann auch mal Gedanken darüber machen müssen, was es so bedeutet, was es bedeutet, autonome Flugmaschinen, autonome Beobachtungsmaschinen, Datenschutzaspekte, da sind natürlich doll spannend. Aber wenn die Dinge dann bewaffnet rumfliegen und nicht mehr zuordnen, wem die gehören, dann haben wir hier als Gesellschaft ein sehr spannendes Thema, dessen wir uns da mal annehmen müssen.
Eigentlich sind es ja fünf Jahre.
Also ich denke, wir müssen jetzt darüber nachdenken.
Bei der gelingen auch mal gleich eine Buchempfehlung von Daniel Suarez, den ja der eine oder andere vielleicht schon mal gelesen hat. Ein US-amerikanischer Schriftsteller mit so Science Fiction, die so in der nahen Zukunft spielen. Er hat ein Buch geschrieben mit dem Titel Kill Decision. Man kann das auch legal erwerben, auf Englisch sogar für einen kleinen Preis. Nur auf Englisch für einen kleinen Preis. Auf Deutsch ist es ja sehr teuer. Wenn es das schon gibt, ich weiß nicht. Auf jeden Fall, das ist ziemlich spannend. Also das spielt eigentlich in der Jetztzeit, aber schon ein bisschen weiter, weil halt überall Drohnen auftauchen und auch in den USA, also in der westlichen Welt, ordentlich rumballern und da geht es eben darum, dass diese Drohnen das eben auch selber entscheiden können, wen sie erschießen. Und das ist schon eine ganz düstere Zukunftsvision, aber sehr spannend geschrieben. Also kann man wirklich zur Einschlaflektur überlegen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, kein wirklich gut geschriebenes Buch, aber eine spannende Idee. Aber wir warten einfach auf die Verfilmung.
Also für die ersten Suarez-Bücher, da Diemen, was ein wirklich sehr lesenswertes Buch gewesen ist, da hat er ja sicher die Filmrechte inzwischen schon verkauft. Und da bin ich immer gespannt, was da draus wird. Anderer Film, der da gerade in der Mache ist, ist ja die Geschichte von WikiLeaks verfilmt. DreamWorks hat da gerade angekündigt.
What?
Ja, ich glaube, Benedict Cumberbatch, der da aus Sherlock auch bekannt ist, der soll bei Assange spielen. Gerade ist der Original-Schauspieler, der Daniel Domscheit-Berg spielen sollte, abgesprungen und Daniel Brühl ist dafür eingesprungen. Und wenn ich die Gerüchtetage richtig verstehe, dann geht es wohl darum, dass die Wikileaks-Geschichte so präsentiert werden soll, dass dort der eine durchgeknallte Typ, also Assange, sich wie diesen armen deutschen Hacker Daniel Domscheit-Berg genommen hat und erst die Kraft der Liebe in Form von Anke dazu geführt hat, dass er dort von diesem verrückten entrissen worden ist.
Okay, die Wahrheit über Wikileaks erfanden wir also nächstes Jahr im Kino.
Ich frag mich...
Warte, ich muss drohen, möchte ich noch kurz sagen. Hatten wir vor nicht allzu langer Zeit eine Chaosradio Sendung? Könnt ihr euch gerne mal anhören, die ist nicht uninteressant. Und ja, was war noch mit dem Film?
Na, ich frag mich mal, wie denn die anderen handeln in Charaktere. Ob dann Kevin Spacey irgendwie Andy Müller Magoon spielt und Maha könnte ja irgendwie von... Ja, genau. Und hier Konstanze Kurz könnte von Sigourney Viva gespielt werden. Da ist ja... da geht was, glaube ich.
Da geht auf jeden Fall was. So, wie gesagt, die Wahl über Wiki liegs nächstes Jahr im Kino. Jetzt kommen wir, nachdem wir die ganze Sendung zurückgeblickt haben, zu einer Vorschau der Kongress. Was? Not My Department, Maha. Du wolltest ja sozusagen genau erklären, was das ist. Oder macht das jemand anders?
Also, Not My Department ist halt ein Zitat. Das ist ein Zitat von Werner von Braun, der angesprochen worden ist auf seine Teilnahme im Nationalsozialismus. Im Besonderen gab es da wohl Leute aus einem Konzentrationslager, die da mitmachen mussten in der Waffenproduktion. Werner von Braun hat auch da Entscheidungen getroffen und hat auch dieses Lager besucht. Und hinterher, als er darauf angesprochen wurde, hat er gesagt, it's not my department. Also er hat dadurch seine Verantwortung so ein bisschen von sich gestreift. Und das ist so ein bisschen die Inspiration eben für dieses Motto, das wir auch haben. Es geht also darum, dass Hacker nicht für bestimmte Firmen arbeiten sollen. Wenn sie das tun, haben sie eben auch Verantwortung. Können die einfach sagen, ich interessiere mich nicht für Politik oder so, it's not my department. Dafür wollen wir halt ein bisschen sensibilisieren, deshalb dieses Motto.
Das hatte dann später Tom Learer in diesem wunderschönen Lied über Werner von Braun aufgenommen, wo er dann gefragt worden ist und der hat dann in den Kontext gereiht, that once the rockets are up, I don't care where they come down, that's not my department. Also solange man erstmal die Raketen in die Luft befördert ist, was ja die Aufgabe eines Wissenschaftlers ist, dann ist mir egal, was dann die Leute, denen man das erfunden hat, damit machen. Und da muss ich dann dieses, keine Ahnung, Department of Conscience und Konsequences mit beschäftigen.
Die anderen. Die anderen TM. Das ist also das Motto des Kongresses. Der ist ja dieses Jahr nicht in Berlin. Weißt du denn das? Das habe ich gehört. Und es gibt noch Karten. Das ließ mich vermuten, es ist nicht in Berlin. Aber wo ist er denn und was passiert da überhaupt?
Dieses Jahr wird der Kongress aus Platz gründen. Und weil wir in Hamburg sehr willkommen geheißen worden sind, genau da hinziehen ins Kongress Center Hamburg, CCH. Was direkt an diesem einen ICE Bahnhof, der von Berlin gut zu erreichen ist, an dessen Name ich mich nicht mehr erinnern kann.
Hamburg Dammtor. Da kannst du also mit dem Bademantel in Berlin einsteigen. Wie Stoiber das mal sagt. Zehn Minuten.
Es ist also in Hamburg, es ist schnell von Berlin erreichbar.
Wir haben dort ein bisschen mehr Platz als in den letzten Jahren. Wir werden schauen, dass wir die Veranstaltung so wachsen lassen, dass es nicht total ungemütlich wird. Wir haben da ja ein Haus zur Verfügung, das wir bespielen möchten, indem wir wieder über 90 ziemlich coole Vorträge auf dem Vortragster-Track, also in drei verschiedenen Sälen, uns anhören können. Und es gibt dieses Jahr das Konzept der Assemblies. Das ist so, wer mal auf dem Camp gewesen ist, das ist so ungefähr wie die Villages. Dass man da so mal... Das sind so kleine Dörfer, in denen sich Leute zusammenfinden, die ähnliche Interessen haben, die an ähnlichen Projekten hacken und die diese gerne präsentieren möchten oder die Gleichgesinnte suchen, um gefunden zu werden. Und da haben sich jetzt auch schon, ich glaube, irgendwie 80 Assemblies angemeldet, die alle ihr kleines Reich bekommen und sich dort zusammenfinden können. Ich bin auf jeden Fall auf dem Kongress, werde da auch einen Jahresrückblick, der vielleicht ein bisschen strukturiert, das heißt die Sendung über den CCC geben. Wir haben dort, ja, wir versuchen, dieses Gemütlichkeitsgefühl, was wir da im BCC in Berlin hinbekommen haben und auch dieses in den letzten Jahren, ob der Tatsache, dass der Kongress so überlaufen ist, gab es ziemlich wenig Leute, die reinschnuppern wollten, einfach nur mal so zu gucken. Dieses Jahr sind einfach noch Karten über und dieses Jahr können einfach Leute vorbeikommen und sagen, ich will mir diesen CCC mal angucken, ich will da vielleicht an einem Tag hin mir mal anschauen, spannende Vorträge, die ich mir vorstellen kann, anzuhören, Fragen zu stellen und danach mich noch mit Leuten, die da auch in dem Vortrag gewesen sind, unterhalten.
Gucken, ob das wirklich so eine Klugscheiße sind.
Aber das mit den Assemblis ist eigentlich eine super Idee. Man kann ja sagen, was ich meine. Also, ich meine, das ist ja immer das Problem in den letzten Jahren gewesen mit diesem Hackcenter. Da war kaum noch Platz und das war überfüllt. Und viele Leute, die gerne was machen wollten, kamen da nicht rein. Und jetzt ist da einfach mal so richtig viel Platz und die Leute können da richtig ihr Zeugs ausfahren und einfach mal zeigen. Also auch so eine Art Leistungsschau.
Eine Chaos-Messe?
Ja, so ein bisschen vielleicht. Aber ich kann mir das super spannend vorstellen, einfach auch um neue Sachen zu entdecken. Das ist für mich ja der besondere Reiz. Ich will da ja irgendwie was Neues entdecken. Das kann man jetzt mal so richtig.
Und nur um das nochmal gefragt zu haben, ich muss kein Ausgleichssystem hinzukommen, sondern es reicht Interesse zu haben.
Das ist ja eigentlich generell die Idee seit immer gewesen. Es gibt diese Berührungsängste, dass hier die totalen Cracks rumhängen würden. Aber das mag vielleicht für einzelne Themen bei den Hackern immer stimmen. Aber natürlich ist jeder einzelne Hacker nicht der totale Auskenn an allen Bereichen und geht genau mit demselben vor, wissen, was eigentlich die Leute da draußen auch haben, in viele andere der dort vorgetragenen Veranstaltungen rein.
Am Tag 3 ist auch Junghackertag. Da gibt es halt auch ein spezielles Angebot für Kinder und Jugendliche, die sich vielleicht das erste Mal überhaupt mit diesen ganzen Themen und all dem auseinandersetzen wollen.
Das erste Mal mit einem Lötkolben.
Ich geh da auch hin. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich mich da verkleiden muss, damit die Leute mich nicht auslachen.
Du bist ja klein.
Ich kann das ja nicht empfehlen. Im letzten Jahr gab es auf dem Kongress eine Rakete, da konnte man sich bunte Lichter zu, irgendwie noch zusammenlöten, das hab ich gemacht. Das befriedigende Gefühl, selber etwas gelötet zu haben, ist nicht schlecht, ich werde trotzdem nicht die Elite-Löter, aber das mal ausprobieren zu haben, ist schon sehr gut.
Wir hatten ja die Datenspuren in Dresden Ende Oktober, und da gab es ja auch unten im Foyer so einen Junkhacker-Lötwerkshop, und das hat wunderbar funktioniert. Ich denke, dass das durchaus hier auch in meinem großen Stil machbar ist.
Für Leute, die interessiert sind, diese Assemblies sind schon im Internet einsehbar. Es gibt unter events.ccc.de, da ist es glaube ich verlinkt, dann slash congress 2012, eine Liste unter anderem der Assemblies. Man kann sich auch selber dort eintragen. Wenn man daran interessiert ist, kann man es kommentieren. Man kann eigene Assemblies dort noch versuchen zu beantragen. Es gibt immer noch auf dem Kongress selber ein Konzept heißt Lightning Talks. Das sind so fünf Minuten Vorträge, die man selber zu seinem Lieblingsthema halten kann, wenn man meint, dass nicht dort ein ganzer Dreiviertel-Stunden-Vortrag daraus wird, aber man mal grob Updates geben möchte. Die kann man auf der Webseite, das ist ein Wiki, kann man da eintragen. Und Partizipationen ist, glaube ich, dieses Jahr ganz groß geschrieben, dass wir einfach mit den neuen Möglichkeiten, die man da hat, mit dem größeren Gebäude, mit diesem Umzug, mit dem gesamten Gefühl, dass jetzt da mal so einige der Verkrustungen über den letzten Jahren, wo es so eingespielt war im BCC, aufgebrochen wurden, dass dort viele spannende Dinge passieren und wir würden da Partizipationen der Gäste auch wieder ganz groß schreiben.
Also das heißt vor allen Dingen auch das Programm, also die Vorträge sind auch schon festgeschrieben. Da kann man jetzt nicht irgendwie noch einen Vortrag einreichen, außer zu diesen Kurztalks. Aber generell, wenn man noch so eine Idee hat für so eine Assemblite, dass man sagt, hier, ich möchte gerne mit meinem Tisch...
Bis Samstag kann man die noch einreichen.
Diesen Samstag?
Diesen Samstag ist eigentlich offizielle Deadline.
Also übermorgen?
Ich glaube, Bernie verwaltet die und die wird mich gleich hassen. Aber wahrscheinlich, wenn man eine coole Assemblite hat, wird man auch später noch mit ein bisschen betteln und nachrutschen können.
Es gibt auch wieder einen Workshopraum, der sich mehr oder weniger selbst organisiert. Also wer da was machen will, braucht sich nicht zurückhalten. Also auch ohne, dass man einen Vortrag eingereicht hat. Einfach hinkommen und was machen. Also da gibt es genug Möglichkeiten diesmal.
Und beim Hinkommen kann man auch sagen, es gibt auf dieser Seite auch ein Wiki, wo sich Leute organisieren, von wegen Mitfahrgelegenheiten und Unterkünfte und alles Mögliche.
Ja, es hört ein Experiment diesmal. Das muss man auch aus euch sehen, aber ich finde das dafür, dass es wirklich so einen experimentellen Charakter hat. Wir vorher nicht wussten, ob wir die Ressourcen wieder zurückgreifen können, irgendwie zwischen Berlin und Hamburg hin und her zu pendeln. Es ist einfach ziemlich cool gelaufen bisher schon. Ich bin da auch, ich freue mich da schon echt drauf.
Jetzt sagen wir mal das Datum.
Datum von was?
Vom Kongress?
Na das findet so nach Weihnachten vor Silvester statt.
Bis 30. Dezember.
Alles klar. So, dann haben wir es eigentlich, oder?
Na mein Internet ist...
Ihr müsst euch jetzt so vorstellen, Chaos Radio ist immer auch so, die Leute sind immer am Computer währenddessen. Und wir haben hier so ein kleines Vorbereitungsdokument, da können wir alle gleichzeitig drin rumarbeiten. Und da steht jetzt seit Anfang der Sendung, ohne Windows 8-Witz geht es nicht, Windows verstehe ich nicht, Maha hat nur noch eins gleichzeitig, eventuell noch mal Salz. Was zur Hölle?
Na, Microsoft ist ja jetzt mit diesem Betriebssystem da rausgekommen, dieses Windows 8.
Betrübssystem.
Und haben damit eigentlich alle Versprechungen, die sie da mit dem Namen und dem Konzept dort gemacht haben ursprünglich, haben sie aufgegeben. Das ist halt nicht mehr Windows, sondern nur noch ein einziges Window. Also Microsoft Window 8.
Das ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen.
Wenn du nicht da ganz groß drum rumhackst, dann siehst du halt nur eins und darfst vielleicht in der Vorschauansicht eines zweiten Fensters von links da mal reingucken lassen. Mehr ist es auch nicht. Ansonsten haben sie mit diesem Versuch dort mal auf Tablets zu gehen und diese X86er, dieser Prozessor, der eigentlich in allen PCs drin ist, da sich da mal verabschieden, um auch Arms zu unterstützen. Das ist nämlich der Prozessor, der in allen Mobiltelefonen und Tablets drin ist. Haben sie denn auch das zweite Versprechen aufgegeben, was sie bisher Leuten garantiert haben, dass ihre alte Software darauf läuft? Das heißt, mit Windows 8 ist man eigentlich gerade irgendwo so zwischen den Welten, zwischen den Stühlen und ich finde, das sollte man umbenennen in Windows 8.
Aber ist es nicht eh so, dass sozusagen nur jedes zweite Windows benutzbar ist?
Ich benutze schon seit Ewigkeiten, also außer meiner Mama sein Windows. Also ich weiß nicht, meins ist benutzbar, meiner Mama seins nicht und da magste Recht haben.
Aber ich finde das nicht gut, dass es da ein Window heißt, weil wir hatten ja schon immer Ex-Window auf dem Unix-System und wenn jetzt irgendwann Windows nur noch Window heißt, dann gibt es noch mehr Verwechslung, vor allen Dingen, wenn die dann das 10. Betriebssystem anfangen.
Und wenn man nur eins sieht, heißt das ja noch lange nicht, dass es nur eins gibt, nicht wahr?
Genau.
Die verstecken sich nämlich nur.
Fiese kleine Dinger. Markus!
Wir gehen uns hier in Details, die sind schon wieder viel zu groß.
Markus!
Ja bitte, was denn?
Willst du jetzt wissen, was der rote Wolf bedeutet?
Der große böse Wolf, was? Der böse Wolf.
Nein, der böse Wolf hat natürlich das Rotkäppchen bedroht. Und da das heute dem Markus seine letzte Sendung ist. Haben die ihm eine kleine Flasche Sekt einer nicht spezifizierten Marke, die den bösen Wolf vielleicht den grob umschrieben ist mitgebracht. Und noch ein kleines Präsent, ein Geduldsspiel, weil du so verdammt viel Geduld mit uns hattest.
Vielen Dank. Ja, jetzt ist es raus.
Und das hier kannst du dir auch noch selber ergründen. Unser schwarzes Schaf in der Hacker-Community.
Ich bin...
Das werden wir in die Webcam halten, aber die sehen das sowieso noch.
Ich setze mal das scharfe Monitor, wenn ihr auf Fritz in die Webcam geht, könnt ihr das dann noch angucken. In den nächsten 10 Minuten wird das bestimmt noch einmal aktualisiert. So, worum geht's hier eigentlich? Also es geht darum, der Herr Richter macht sich jetzt von dann, ich höre bei Fritz...
Ich geh in die Babypause.
Ich höre bei Fritz auf und werde Mutter. Nee, Quatsch. Und deswegen war das jetzt das letzte Chaosradio mit mir und auch generell wird mich hier nicht mehr hören. Es hat mir viel Spaß gemacht mit euch. Und ich übergebe das Chaosradio zum Beispiel an jemanden, der sich eigentlich noch mal melden wollte heute, aber irgendwie das nicht mehr getan hat. Aber das kennt man von ihm auch schon und man kennt ihn auch schon. Also die nächsten Chaosradios, die euch allen werden, wird ein gewisser Herr Klein moderieren. Der Holgi. Genau, der hat das auch schon mal gemacht. Mit guten Händen.
Um genau zu sein, war meine erste Chaosradiosendung, die ich hier mit bestritten habe, war mit dem Holgi. Da saß ich, glaube ich, mit dem Bert, der jetzt auch gerade neben mir sitzt.
Das waren noch Zeiten. Da haben wir noch die Webcam umgedreht.
Und damals gab es auch... Also die Sendung war, glaube ich, dieses Wi-Fi. Wo muss der hier sein? Total der krasse, heiße neue Shit.
Die Schweine. Jetzt kommen hier Leute ins Studio.
Um Gottes Willen, was passiert hier?
Du kannst seine Daten nicht richtig spüren.
Ich suche für meine Damen und Herren.
Da ist er.
Wir stören nur sehr ungern dieses kleine akustische Tett a Tett hier. Aber es handelt sich hier um einen kleinen Notfall. Herr Richter, ich darf uns kurz vorstellen, wir sind ein kleines Spezialeinsatzkommando.
Mein Name ist Schmidt.
Mit Doppel T. Hallo Herr Schmidt. Sehr erfreut, Ihre Bekanntschaft zu machen. Haben Sie einen Auftrag für mich? Wir sind von einem speziellen Einsatzteam. Wir sind die freien Rächer in turbulenten Zeiten.
Kurz Fritz.
Ich darf kurz vorstellen. Agent SchragEi hier an meiner Seite. Wir haben ebenfalls an meiner Seite Agentin Katzenschmidt. Und nicht zu vergessen natürlich unseren Koordinator Captain Ahab Jonstortier, seines Zeichens Captain der Ushimira.
Herr Richter, unseren Aufzeichen zufolge ist dies Ihr letzter Blue Moon. Sehen wir das richtig?
Das ist mir zugetragen worden, ja.
Das trifft sich ganz hervorragend. Wir haben einen Auftrag für Sie. Wie Sie unschwer erkennen können, sind wir soeben durch einen Zeitportal aus der Zukunft in Ihre Welt eingedrungen. Der Grund dafür ist folgender. Es ist sehr wichtig, in unserer Zeit im Jahr 2112 herrscht Krieg zwischen den Digitalgroßmächten Google und Apple. Aufgrund unzähliger Cyberattacken sind die Datenverluste auf beiden Seiten erheblich.
Unser Einsatzteam hat es sich quasi zur Aufgabe gemacht, einzuschreiten. Aber für unseren Plan, da fehlt noch jemand, der Ahnung hat von diesen ganzen Krämpel. Und deswegen müssen Sie mitkommen, weil Sie sind der Einzige, der noch weiß, wie man Backups macht. Und deswegen müssen Sie sich uns anschließen. Sie haben da keine andere Wahl. Und deswegen sind Sie unsere letzte Rettung, die letzte Rettung der Menschheit. Und deswegen auf ins Demissionsportal.
Ja, liebe Leute, also das ist dann wirklich der Punkt, wo ich einfach nur noch das Terrain hier verlassen kann. Es hat mir sehr viel Spaß gemacht mit euch.
Der Markus hat Pipi in den Augen.
Ich bin dann mal raus und muss auch ein bisschen weinen und ich will euch aber noch, also bevor die mich hier wirklich entführen...
Herr Richter, die Rückwegkoordinaten sind bereits aktiviert. Wir haben keine Zeit zu verlieren.
Also ich habe dann tatsächlich nur noch eine Sache zu sagen, bevor das Rückwärtskoordinatensystem mich hier mitnimmt, macht bitte immer schön eure Backups und lasst euch nicht überwachen. Beeilse sich!
Wir halten uns auf!
Entschuldigung, das tut nur ein bisschen leid.
Und da der Markus gerade schreiend das Studio verlassen hat, muss sich der Erdgeist vom CCC von euch verabschieden. Die nächste Sendung findet am 31. Januar statt. Im Dezember haben wir nämlich ein Kongress und dann mit Holger Klein. Und ich freue mich auf euch.
Ein Podcast von fritz.de